there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
later hey you guys uh we're having big
problems if this i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on with this [ __ ] like as
soon as it comes on it's like yeah it'll
could be like green green green then
it's like red red red red
it's green now but yeah um
yeah well that's the stupid thing i i
just bought a [ __ ] wi-fi booster
because the
the router is like way the [ __ ]
downstairs and i was like well maybe
we're having problems because the
router's so far away
so i got a booster that i put up here
and it has like and i attached to like
even a lan cable and stuff like that but
the first time we tried to do the live
stream it was just like not having it it
just like immediately went to red and it
wouldn't go and then i tried to like and
there's password problems yeah and then
like it's telling me that the password
isn't right even though i just set up
that password like literally a few hours
ago so i don't really know what the [ __ ]
is going on with that seems to be
holding i mean
much like uh
everything i buy to improve the stupid
[ __ ] connection in this place it's
like it just doesn't [ __ ] work and
it's really really frustrating it's a
hardware problem so i don't really know
uh what the problem is but hopefully
hopefully because it does seem like we
do have
problems around this time at like five
five o'clock zach says welcome to lag
city population us yeah tell me about it
i'm like it just and i hate when it
happens like right out the gate like
that because then it just puts me in a
really bad head space and then i just
see her when she [ __ ] loses i just
can't even think well i get [ __ ]
frustrated you know what i mean it's
like so frustrating because i have
everything i spend so much time like
setting everything up it's like you know
i do all these notes and i make all the
stuff and it's like i set everything up
like way ahead of time and then it's
just like nope not gonna work for some
reason that i'm not gonna tell you what
it is so it's very very very frustrating
when it should work you know
it should work but it just stream looks
steady it does not
uh
murder hornet returns jenny your gift
should be there friday hand painted
thank you very much i'm very very happy
about that i think we'll be here
tomorrow i mean you know it's wednesday
it usually shows up early if they say
friday usually here thursday i'm kind of
hoping that oh i forgot to check the
mail today actually because we ordered
some uh some new shiba shiba meat sticks
for pookie i can go down because we'll
be really upset
[Music]
i mean if you want yeah we got insane
she's got i mean if they came they would
i would have gotten a message so i'm
sure they're not here
but um i mean there might be other stuff
in the mail and it goes right again
awesome awesome
i [ __ ] love it i love it
[Music]
my god come on you piece of [ __ ]
i don't know it's like i don't
understand why other people don't have
these [ __ ] problems like this laptop
is not old
nothing in here is old you know what i
mean
that [ __ ] booster i bought is brand
new i just bought it
like and it's a new like a nice one i
don't understand why shit's not working
so you know
great
it's just great and i'm like i said i
hate it when it's
right at the beginning of the show
because i get so [ __ ] frustrated and
then i'm like already kind of in a bad
mood like when it starts and it just
like makes me so bad and it's just like
i'm just
i don't know so it like puts me on edge
because i'm like then the rest of the
night i'm gonna be like looking down at
it like obsessively and like it's gonna
cut off it's gonna cut off oh my god and
it's just i don't know pisses me off i
know
you know it's like i know you guys like
feel the frustration but
it's just kind of like i hate to have to
do [ __ ] in like
several parts you remember that show
that we did a couple weeks back
and i think it just kept shutting off
and the [ __ ] show i think it was the
dr kellogg one and i think that show
ended up being like four [ __ ] in four
[ __ ] pieces because it just kept
turning off and i kept getting so like
frustrated and we just had to keep
restarting but
i'm just you know i'm trying not to
punch the laptop i'm trying to be zen
about it
but
you know
uh yeah so
uh aliases is a hard line possible
meaning uh well i did have
that's a problem i have a lan cable and
the router huh oh the router is too far
away for me to hook it up up here
but i did have the lan cable hooked up
to the booster
but that was not uh working for whatever
reason so i unplugged it before i like
restarted everything but it's right
there i don't know we'll see if it works
oh how it got so [ __ ] hot in here
i don't know it must be you radiating
heat because usually it's like really
cold in here it's [ __ ] usually it's
so cold in here that i have to like put
my little jacket on
because it's like [ __ ] freezing i am
pretty cranked up but
it's [ __ ] hot
you're pretty cranked up
i'm pretty jacked
yeah it's like i know i can smell you
from over here you can't i know i'm just
kidding
i can't really
i increased some [ __ ] i increased some
[ __ ]
increasing testosterone
no you're just making everything like
warmer and more uncomfortable for
everybody
oh my god yeah so hopefully if this
stupid [ __ ] connection
uh maintains which it better or i'm
gonna kick its ass if i can find it uh
this should be a fun show tonight i'm
actually really glad because i don't
think i ever would have thought
necessarily to do this as an episode
but
i mean i might have done something like
on my own show or whatever but this was
actually a really good idea for an
episode uh and i don't think even though
i'm a big huge horror nerd i don't think
i ever would have thought about doing it
even though
it's super fun and like i said
who doesn't love christopher lee and
peter cushing come on everybody loves
them uh everybody that's worked with
them loves them
everybody that's watched their movies
love them even when they're in shitty
ass movies they're always awesome
and
i mean their movies are cool they're
just cool ass people they were just cool
ass people and uh you know so it'll be
cool like to be able to talk about them
i haven't watched a couple of their
movies today get me in the mood i wanted
to see two that i hadn't seen before
because i haven't seen all of the movies
because obviously the christopher lee
did what 208 movies over the course of
his career i think he was i don't know
if he still is but i think if for a time
i think he was like the guy that had
been in the most movies you know what i
mean yeah it's more versus meredith yeah
so 208 movies and uh peter cushing had
been in 100 like 100 something and uh 24
of those they were in together not
necessarily like as a team up sometimes
they were just you know particularly
early in their careers they would be in
a movie together but like they weren't
like on screen together you know what
i'm saying yeah but they take it they
knew each other uh they were like best
friends and that's not even like an
exaggeration they were best friends uh
from 1957 onwards uh until peter cushing
died in 1994
they were like seriously besties
and
it's so cool that's what's so cool to me
and actually you know what's even cooler
than that when that's pretty cool is
that they were also really good friends
with vincent price can you imagine
how awesome that would be like hanging
out with the three of them
because they were all like buddies and
i'm like how [ __ ] adorable and
awesome is that that is so [ __ ] cool
i just love it because it would really i
don't know why it's like it would really
make me sad if i had seen all these
movies with christopher lee and peter
cushing in it and then i heard oh yeah
they hated each other
you know and yeah and i was like ah
that'd be like a real bummer but it's
like no they were like total best
friends they hung out it's like it's
super cool and honestly like after peter
cushing died
like some of the stuff that christopher
lee like said about him and stuff was
like was really really awesome but
it's you know it just like makes me
happy so today i watched because like i
said i haven't seen all of the movies
that they did together i've seen most of
them
but
i wanted to watch a couple that i hadn't
seen before
with both of them in it so i watched the
gorgon
which is on to be
uh which was pretty good and also i
watched uh hound of the baskervilles
and because for some reason i don't
think i had ever seen that one or if i
if if i did i was really young and that
was really good i liked that a lot
um i was also gonna watch
uh shutter had a bunch of peter cushing
movies
but it looks like they've taken most of
them down they still have
uh horror express up there which is
another good one that both of them were
in and then they have the one that just
had peter cushing in it that was about
birken hair
uh and i was gonna watch that but i
didn't have enough time also i listened
to a little bit of christopher lee's uh
symphonic metal album from 2010
charlemagne yeah uh it's pretty rad i
gotta say um he did a couple like yeah
he did a lot of symbol yeah he did a lot
of symphonic metal like later on in his
career when he was and because he has
like a great [ __ ] uh singing voice
you know what i mean because he had a
great speaking voice as well what does
it sound like
heavy metal or kind of but it's kind of
like metal but it's like operatic okay
and it's almost kind of like a heavy
metal i don't want to say it sounds like
a musical because that sounds like
that's a whole different thing but it's
it's a story it's about charlemagne
and
you know but in musical form so it's
kind of like character singing in other
words kind of like looking um
uh
merciful fate with king diamond that's
all yeah kinda all right you sing songs
the whole whole album is a damn concept
album about ghosts and [ __ ]
uh yeah somebody uh who was it that said
um
that uh peter cushing's best movie was
cash on demand and honestly yeah i don't
think i've seen that one but i think
that was actually one of his favorite
roles even though
uh it was the one that's the least seen
the cool thing about them too it's like
even though i think both in their own
way
they were bummed out by being
typecast in horror movies
but they seem to have like a pretty good
sense of humor about it i mean
christopher lee they're making money
well that's the thing i mean christopher
lee was kind of like i mean chris really
did you know probably twice as many
movies as peter cushing did um and
another thing too is that they didn't
really start acting until later on in
life not like later later they weren't
old or anything but
it's not like um peter cushing was
really into acting from a very young age
but he didn't really get recognized uh
to any great degree until he was like
middle aged you know what i'm saying 40
yeah something like that um you know he
had done stage [ __ ] and uh you know had
bit parts in movies and everything but
um he didn't really get well known until
a little bit later which i thought
because honestly he i think he was in
his 40s and he thought
he'd been in some stuff but he was like
you know broke and he was just kind of
like i failed you know i wanted to be
that's all i ever wanted to be was an
actor but he failed but then he you know
hooked up with hammer and then the rest
is history
so and i kind of feel like even though
you know they're associated with hammer
obviously both of them
but both of them did so much other stuff
too but i feel like if they hadn't done
the hammer movies maybe less so
christopher lee because he was in like
lord of the rings and [ __ ]
from star wars yeah well peter cushing
was in star wars too yeah um and
honestly he really he was really into
that because he's like that brought a
whole obviously a new generation
uh you know it into his work but yeah he
was like he wasn't really a big fan of
horror or sci-fi and usually that kind
of makes me sad but
he did say peter cushing did say he was
like well he's like you know nobody
really wants to see me as hamlet it's
like if you want to see me as dr van
helsing and stuff so that's what i want
to do i want to do stuff that like makes
me happy makes people happy and what
they want to see me in so you know he
seemed to be pretty cool about it and he
honestly um
was really uh he said he was like really
touched by people that like wrote him
letters like talking about how much they
loved his you know you know stuff in the
hammer movies and everything like that
so they both seem to have a pretty good
christopher lee i think was more
because i mean after like he did the
hammer movies and then he was kind of
like well i don't really want to do
like every time they were they would do
like another dracula movie and they'd be
like christopher lee you have to do the
dracula movie and he's like no
and then they were kind of like yeah but
all of these people like we're doing
this other dracula movie and it's like
they're get they're not going to get a
paycheck if you don't come and do this
dracula movie because we already said
that you would do it and then he's like
okay fine so i do kind of feel like they
sort of he called it like emotionally
manipulated him into doing a lot of the
dracula movies but to his credit he
never phoned that [ __ ] in even in the
like really cheesy ones like dracula 80
1972 which actually i kind of have a
soft spot for even though it's like i
remember that one even though it's like
pretty cheesy well it's you know
dracula's still dracula but peter
cushing peter cushing was in it but he
had to play
like the grandson of van helsing because
it's supposed to be groovy 1972 so they
really did try to do like they tried to
groovy it up
to you know
well it's maybe only partial success it
is a fun it's not one of the better ones
i don't think honestly i think the the
better ones were like the more serious
ones honestly when i was watching hound
of the baskervilles today i was like
amazed that i don't think i'd ever seen
that one because that one's really good
the gorgon's pretty good too but
you know it's it's
low budget obviously but i thought it
was cool like the mythological angle i
kind of liked the
the gorgon lady that they had but you
know what's what are you gonna do
uh so yeah what uh what are we gonna do
are we gonna um i guess we're gonna
start the show right are we i don't know
do we have any well i'm just you know
i'm having a little kind of like
discussion about it i don't want to be
too like rigid about the [ __ ] like how i
have [ __ ] laid out
is i just kind of had like biography
like christopher lee biography peter
cushing biography i have like a little
list of films at the end that they were
in together like the 24 of them so we
can talk about those if you want but
obviously
after certain points uh you know their
biographies are going to overlap
so
if we want to kind of go off in a
direction or if you want to go off on a
direction when we talk about various
things then that's fine too this like i
said i want this to be kind of like
just a fun show just a fun show because
you know i'm i'm really into these two
guys i really love their movies
and
i've seen a lot of them i don't really
know a whole lot about them i've seen
seen their movies but personally i don't
really know that much about them
yeah
i know that um
i know christopher lee
would he could fly planes
and yeah he had something to do with
james bond and ian fleming
they were related or something um
by well yeah i think by marriage yeah
wasn't it yeah i'll get into that like
uh yeah and well he was in a bond film
wasn't he was in uh man with the golden
guy yeah
but um
yeah so so like i said i kind of feel
like he was
i mean they both were really they were
very diverse actors i do kind of feel
like everybody remembers them nowadays
because of horror and also because of
star wars and lord of the rings and
chris christopher lee's case but they
did so much other [ __ ] too i mean peter
cushing played sherlock holmes a
shit-ton and he was really into sherlock
holmes he even uh wrote like he would
write the four words to like books about
sherlock holmes like about the sherlock
holmes phenomenon so he was super into
that
but it's interesting too like reading
their backstories
they really
they're they're really like two
completely different people like where
they came from and stuff not where they
came from like literally but
i don't know like personality wise
but
i think what they shared was this kind
of
gentlemanly
like a very old-fashioned gen not
old-fashioned in a bad way but like just
a gentlemanly kind of
bearing
that uh you know that they kind of like
and everybody says that about peter
cushing in particular that he was like
the loveliest
like this just this gentle soft-spoken
kind of dude who like wouldn't hurt a
fly you know what i mean he was that
kind of guy whereas christopher lee was
kind of more
christopher lee like you said he was
almost like a real life james bond like
i said if you if you read his biography
you're just like that was one dude holy
crap he's like he's super badass yeah
from what i remember he had the
reputation for being kind of like a
british badass yeah you know but he
wasn't like when the mean guy was just
he just didn't give a [ __ ] he didn't
care about getting his [ __ ] hands
dirty he'd do evidently he'd do
dangerous [ __ ]
and he and the i think the cool thing
about him was that he didn't really like
brag about it either
like there was some stuff that he just
like later on he wouldn't really talk
about it even though people asked him
about it's like hey we've heard about
when you were a nazi hunter and all this
other stuff and he's just like yeah that
was kind of [ __ ] up you know what i
mean it's like he wouldn't really like
go into like yeah i'm so awesome like
yeah so i kind of feel like that was
maybe why a little bit but a lot of
people don't uh
like like him too
uh
let's see yeah dom the bomb says peter
cushing's wife died 25 years before he
died he was very in love and he never
buried again yeah and honestly this is
like so so sad
peter cushing and his wife will get into
this uh they married in the 40s i want
to say was like 1943
and then she died and after that
he basically he kept working and stuff
but
he said to an interviewer he said well
i'm basically just like killing time
until i die and see her again yeah agent
what look at that
she gets sick oh no
yeah i guess she did well you get sick
oh maybe that wet food makes her sick
too yeah i guess it just happened huh i
guess i didn't see that earlier she's
looking at me like yeah she's like yeah
let's clean it up that's what that's uh
weird she doesn't usually she doesn't
usually
get it it's just it's not big she
doesn't usually throw up yeah but see
we've been having problems that wet food
we've been giving it i mean we gave it
to pookie before but we have been giving
it to beijing but beijing can't eat it
without throwing up
uh but beijing is much older
so
so i've been giving it to pookie and it
seems fine she hasn't like thrown up or
anything so that's like the first time
she's thrown like a hairball that just
came up in one piece oh okay gross
[Laughter]
it's live [ __ ] we have cats
throwing up in the background she must
have just done that yeah so i don't know
if i was like
yelling at the computer when it happened
it was a hairball because it just came
up it just picked up i guess so yeah oh
it's starting to go red oh no no no no
no no because i moved
yeah maybe
it's because we said cat hair ball
cat hair balls come on it's coming back
okay
uh
yeah so that's it yeah we'll get into
that because that's like pretty sad it
probably
if it's if it's uh skip and tell us
people if it's well it is obviously
because it's okay it may or may not be
skipping sometimes it'll do that and
they can hear us right through it
yeah i mean i try not to say anything
super important yeah most of the time
they can hear it when it goes red
because because i you know i don't know
like i said if you guys use obs there's
a very clear little square right there
yeah and it goes you know it changes
color like depending on how good the
connection is
so as soon as it starts going yellow and
orange i'm just kind of like oh no
uh hugo asks what are my top movies of
uh peter cushing and christopher lee
honestly um
uh okay i'm a big fan of uh horror of
dracula which i think in the uk is just
known as dracula but in the us it's
known as horror of dracula the 1957 one
obviously that one's amazing um pound to
the baskervilles which like i said i
just saw today uh is pretty [ __ ] rad
um big fan of horror express also which
we reviewed that not too long ago right
that was the one of the remember the one
the two of them on the train
with the monster in the crate
and i had forgotten this until i was
watching like some other thing today
about uh the two of them
and
that
movie was also loosely based on who goes
there the same novel john w campbell i
think wrote
that you know
john carpenter's the thing was based on
which
you wouldn't really know if you watched
it but then
once you know that you're kind of like
oh yeah now i can see it but yeah so the
two of them are in that so i really like
that one
um
also kind of a big fan of the creeping
flesh to be honest i know a lot of
people don't bring that one up but i
kind of dig that one i don't know what
it is about it but i mean a lot of the
dracula ones are good curse of
frankenstein is great uh the mummy is
good like the version of the mummy that
they did which had christopher lee
playing the mummy that was also pretty
awesome
but i don't know any time the two of
them are in a movie together it's always
like a good time i don't even care what
the movie is you know what i'm saying
i'm trying to look because i have this
uh list down here of like all the movies
they were in together
and
um
yeah we reviewed the skull didn't we
that one was all right i didn't love it
but i mean two of them were really good
in it
one that i haven't seen that i really
want to see
is i monster which is like jekyll and
hyde
both of them were in that that came in
1971 and i don't think i've seen that
one dr terra's house of horrors is
pretty good too now that i'm thinking
about it but probably probably horror of
dracula is probably my favorite but
i don't know there's a lot of other ones
that i like in there um let's see where
are we
okay so we're still green so that's fine
uh yeah mango says the creeping flesh is
a forgotten classic i mean i don't know
there's just something about that one i
really like i really like i don't know i
just really like the concept behind it i
think i reviewed it not too long ago
um
i don't know i just like that whole
thing of like that big huge skeleton and
like the flesh like forming over it and
like i don't know it's i really like
that one i first saw that when i was a
kid and then i saw it again later and i
thought that was kind of cool but uh
yeah horror express the thing's distant
cousin yes as we were talking about
earlier
and uh yeah so
uh [ __ ] i was gonna say something uh
harry
says i hope tom gets hellish wasted on
today on today's show yeah i probably
will he probably will you know what i
mean yeah uh mango says you've not seen
eye monster i haven't i wanted like i
said i was trying to watch today i was
trying to you know catch up on the ones
that i hadn't seen so i did watch the
gorgon today because i hadn't seen that
one and i saw and i watched how to the
baskervilles and i was gonna watch a
couple other ones too but i didn't have
time
but um yeah that's i think that's the
one that i mainly want to see
uh the both of them are in that i
haven't uh seen yet yeah manga says it's
a must-see yeah that's definitely next
on my list so yeah all right so
you want to get into this yeah you got
like all the all the
angelic light shining on you is it yeah
[Laughter]
i found pookie earlier i went out in the
hall and she was in the gym
like sitting right exactly like in this
square of sunlight that was coming in
from the window and she was just like
yeah like
i don't know she hangs out in here
though where it's dark but i guess she
wanted to sit in some sunshine
she's down there getting ready to play
yeah you get ready to play pokey feeling
all right yeah she doesn't usually throw
up maybe it was just we did a hair ball
we did give her some wet food just yeah
so
she doesn't usually ask for it this late
in the day i give her some in the
morning so maybe she was just kind of
like oh i'm hungry and then she's like
oh i shouldn't have eaten so much
you know no
i don't think it was she's always asking
for food yeah uh mango says i think it's
on amazon i have it on blu-ray i will
look for it later because i definitely
do want to watch that like i said the
ones i watched um the gorgon and hound
of the baskervilles are on 2b for free
some of the other ones are you know on
amazon but you have to pay like to rent
them
so there's that all right so let's get
into
christopher lee's biography we'll do
that first why not christopher lee born
in 1922 uh in london
now his dad was a
first world war hero a lieutenant
colonel on the uh king's royal rifle
corps
and at the time that christopher lee was
born uh his dad was married to an
italian countess of all things
countess estelle marie
okay so uh so yeah so uh christopher lee
is half italian in case you uh did not
know
now his mom
actually uh you know as many countesses
are quite famous she was actually uh
distant
distantly related or actually directly
related to charlemagne i believe going
back a long way clearly
and she'd also been uh painted and
sculpted and stuff like that by a lot of
different uh famous artists of her day
so there was that also
uh so because this was kind of
that def it's not nobility is it really
i mean i guess countess that's kind of
nobody right well aristocracy yeah it's
aristocracy so yeah it was a very
aristocratic type of upbringing i guess
you know in that period a lot of times
well actually the aristocracy basically
wrong welfare basically
they just get a [ __ ] chat cut to them
must be nice yeah they get to live as
they have become accustomed yeah like me
[Laughter]
i i wish i could become accustomed to
something yeah i live as i've become
accustomed to like i'm accustomed to
like being broke as [ __ ] right
it's kind of like welfare you know a
taxpayer they were living off a taxpayer
money well the royal family still does
do they not yeah i mean it was kind of
like being being a cracker you know what
they call them like a kentucky colonel
you know yeah you got the job as a
kentucky colonel just walked around and
[ __ ] broke ground on new construction
and wore a white suit and got paid just
to show up to a [ __ ] i can do that
function i don't look good in white but
if i could just like
just do that and have all the money i
wanted the ceremony yeah i'll do it just
ceremonial position
dj maniac so he's not chinese and bruce
lee's dad y'all [ __ ] lied to my ass
and he played foo manchu yeah that's
right he did play foot manchester
several times actually but that's kind
of the thing i mean you saw it
in hollywood
going way back
uh anybody that looked a little bit
quote unquote ethnic
you know they all was wrong got to play
they didn't even care what ethnicity you
were what you're half italian you look
kind of exotic yeah let's put let's put
some like let's darken darken your face
up a little bit and pull your eyelids
out yeah some [ __ ] now you're chinese
yeah yeah but yeah he was he was a half
white and half italian so there you go
not not chinese at all
but oh well
what are you gonna do this well i kind
of feel like fu manchu
um
actually was played by
god i feel like that he was played by a
lot of white actors boris garloff
yeah that's right
half british half indian that's true
which closer but still
still not ideal but okay that's a little
bit better i guess
uh but yeah so so yeah it was a very
aristocratic
household yeah it wasn't that far back i
mean man of old [ __ ] tom baker doctor
who there was a whole
uh series uh it was called the uh the
towns of wang chang and it was
[ __ ] it was basically a ripoff on fu
manchu and they had a british guy
dressed up as a chinese dude with his
eyes done and everything but it was
great it was great yeah and it was it
didn't have anything it wasn't racist or
anything they were just
trying to put a [ __ ] famous actor
into into a [ __ ] badass role yeah i
don't really think they thought they
thought of it as problematic like back
in the old days no i was respectful they
were [ __ ] dude they were just kind of
like chinese well this is a famous actor
and this is a movie that we're making
and he's gonna be in it right he's just
he's gonna pay he's gonna play this role
and look and they had all this cool
chinese [ __ ] and it was chinese stuff
from the future that had come back
actually no
that was a good series it was about
traveler who went into the past by
accident
and he was to escape in war try war
crimes tribunals like in the year
[ __ ] 21 something and he ends up in
in china and impersonates a chinese
demigod and he has a whole cult and
everything he's using and he used
technology to keep himself alive into
the late 1800s and that's where [ __ ]
doctor who meets him and realizes that
this dude is from the future he's a time
traveler but his time travel [ __ ] him
up makes him all kind of twisted and he
had a thing with him called mr sin it
was a little [ __ ]
robotic doll it was a cyborg had it was
run by a pig brain and he was using it
as a damn uh as a as a as a
ventriloquist dummy in his act but it
was going out killing people it's pretty
cool it could talk
there was a pig brain running it
a good idea when you think about it i
could believe that the world's being run
by a pig brain wasn't it
wasn't the world it was a robot no i
don't know what to say yeah
it was like a like a cybernetic robot
yeah oracle says christopher lee's
italian ancestry led to him being cast
as baddies in the uk because he looked
foreign and therefore evil yeah i kind
of feel like a lot of that happened it
just looked british to me it's funny and
uh yeah yeah
to us they all just like like british
white dudes but yeah but i guess over
there he's like well he's not quite
white enough yeah you know what i mean
he just wasn't
i think he's coming back that might be
from the wig though
i don't know
all right it's back all right it's back
we don't know what the hell is going on
ah
it's just making me angry maybe my anger
is like making it worse you guys
although i wasn't angry before it
started doing that if it would just be
nice i would just be happy about it but
no
granthar says i wholly reject the notion
of blood privilege and the idea of being
born into royalty
yeah it does kind of blow i mean
i just you have all these like useless
ass people just like laying around it's
like oh i was born they don't have to
like do [ __ ] to like make anything well
back in the day they had to [ __ ]
actually had to work for that money they
had to be leaders but then they got
retired
or
a dem democracy or something right now
they just lay around in their place
and then just get up and shuffle around
in their pjs and have tea brought to
them and well i think they're venture
capitalists now man i wish i had a bank
like that i would i would love to just
shuffle around all day at my pjs yeah
[Laughter]
and i was like hey bring me some cookies
i think they're venture capitalists they
tend to be super super rich so they own
[ __ ]
adriana says the reason christopher lee
is hot is because he's outfitted half
italian just saying
yeah yeah uh
right now it just looks like another
white dude
well
well like i said i guess back then they
were a lot more concerned what did they
have like a little pantone colored strip
thing we're just like it's you know you
are this white you know what i mean
because honestly yeah if you had told me
and the same thing about boris karloff
you know if you had told me that he was
half indian
like a long time like it it just never
occurred to me he just looked like a
generic i don't know it's it's just
something i never really like noticed i
guess
but maybe back then they noticed more
like i said they just they weren't white
enough he looked a little bit
but you know i guess
uh let's see all right so where was i
all right so this was kind of like a
like i said an aristocratic family so
they had a lot of like nobles dropping
by and [ __ ] like that
now uh christopher leo's he had a second
sis he had a sister named zandra uh who
was older than him she was born in 1917
but um honestly when christopher was
four his parents actually separated
and for the next couple of years the
kids lived with their mom the countess
in switzerland
and their dad stayed back in london at
their old house uh and then after two
years uh the you know they were
officially divorced
now while they were in switzerland uh
the countess
put her son put christopher into a
preschool called miss fisher's academy
and it was here that he got his first
acting role
he played rumpelstiltskin
in a play
uh so 1928 they go back to england
and uh he gets put into a private school
and in 1929 his mom the countess
remarried uh she married a banker whose
name was harcourt george saint croix
rose jesus christ these names
um
and this is where you're getting the ian
fleming connection the step dad
was the uncle of ian fleming so they
were essentially like step cousins okay
you know what i'm saying yeah so he was
distantly related by marriage to ian
fleming
uh so then uh after they got married
then they moved to fulham back in
england and then christopher lee goes to
a boarding school in oxford
and uh so basically he started like i
said he was kind of into acting a little
bit but i don't think he really saw it
as a career prospect until later i think
he just kind of did it
you know for fun although he did um
actually end up going to school with
patrick mcnay who
you know very famous british actor he
was uh john steed in the avengers yeah
among many i think yeah that guy uh so
he did and uh christopher lee makes the
joke that you know i was in all these
things but patrick mcnee always got the
lead you know what i mean like in the
things that they were always in so you
know uh but they were you know they
actually showed up together in a lot of
different plays now this school that he
went to was called summer fields and it
was one of those boarding schools that
um then they would send you on to eaton
college which is kind of like the big
fancy upper crust whatever
um the thing about it though
is that uh christopher lee
he goes to do this the exam uh to go to
eaton in 1935
uh and he was really good at a lot of
things but he was terrible at math
yeah and so uh that apparently
you know he didn't get a scholarship
because of that but he was good at
everything else though
now so he didn't get a scholarship so
had he wanted to go on to eaton his
parents he could have but his parents
would have
i don't know and i'm not doing anything
that's what well i didn't say you were
worried i was just reconnected i haven't
i have no idea i don't know why it's
doing that it's some kind of it's some
kind of it's it's data
it has something to do with that thing
well i don't know that thing inside that
thing with the thing yeah that must be
it is that that thank you for your input
yeah
that's very helpful yeah it's that it's
it's that wireless
well yeah i know
it's well honestly i think a lot of it
has to do with like uh the time
because
sometimes we stream and it's fine we
have absolutely no problems and then
sometimes like i was brought up earlier
when we did like the dr kellogg show and
it just kept cutting off and kept
cutting off and i ended up like the show
being in four [ __ ] parts because it
just kept disconnecting
um so yeah sheila anne said what's going
on how's the weather down there that's
the thing the weather is is perfect it's
like
you know
partly sunny 69 degrees no wind there's
lots of no clouds there's no nothing
there's a lot of construction around
here though
i don't know we're building all those
houses that maybe i don't know if
there's anything to do with it but
they're getting in the way their fat
asses are getting in the way of my
wireless just they're blocking out the
wireless could be that it could be that
they're building houses in here and it's
[ __ ] sucking up all the internet that
the infrastructure wasn't designed yeah
maybe all the [ __ ] around here are
like well well i kind of think that too
because to be honest
as i said it it seems like a lot of the
houses they're not old but i think they
only got wi-fi out here like not that
long ago
and it really does seem like they're
building houses faster than the [ __ ] can
keep up
so they had it out here 10 years ago
when i lived out here though did they
yeah how good was it not good
although you were okay although you
weren't live streaming no you weren't
live streaming
back in those days data requirements
weren't as great that's what i'm saying
so i think it's like not really keeping
up yeah maybe
because we didn't i mean we did have a
little bit of trouble like back at the
old house but we've had a lot more
trouble since we came here yeah you know
i mean because this is like kind of
farther out in the middle of nowhere
it's not in the middle of nowhere it's
just it's in between two
yeah it's just in between two big towns
it's sort of like rural but yeah
so let me see i don't even know where i
got cut off
um
[Music]
but i was talking about christopher lee
and
wanting to go to eaton and sitting at
the exam but
failing out on a scholarship because he
sucked at math
and so since his parents would have had
to pay to send him to eaton because he
didn't get a scholarship uh his parents
said no and so he went to wellington
college now when he was at wellington
college
uh one thing that he turned out that he
was very good at uh among the million
other things that he's very good at was
languages
the [ __ ] speaks
eight languages
uh five fluently and three good enough
that he can communicate effectively
uh obviously english uh he can speak
french spanish italian and german
uh and he could passively speak
russian greek and swedish okay uh
somebody languages don't have anything
to do with each other somebody did yeah
so he was really good at that and
honestly somebody did i saw like a
little super cut that somebody did on
youtube of him speaking his five
different uh you know his five hundred
languages at various uh you know
locations like when he was older like at
different functions
and in the comments people whose native
languages were french spanish german
italian were kind of laughing because
they said one of the first things he
says like oh sorry my german's not very
good and they said is german is like
perfect they're like he sounds like a
native speaker
um so yeah he was really really good at
languages not so good at math but okay
you can't be good at
everything terrible
languages are easy
i'm passable at math um it's not my
favorite subject but i wasn't i wasn't
bad at it i was okay at it i'm better at
like more english type things but i
wasn't i wasn't like math challenging
jumping from one language to the next
just
just like out of the blue with no warm
up you have to like become immersed in
it after a while then it starts like you
start remembering
because like i don't really speak
portuguese that often anymore
i hear it i hear it if i i'll watch i'll
watch portuguese stuff on like stuff
from brazil on youtube
uh and it takes a while to make that
adjustment
you know what i mean you're still like
oh yeah yeah yeah it starts coming back
to you
used to be i have a dream in portuguese
but it hasn't been that way some while i
mean i kind of feel like that happens
anytime you like learn a language when
you're younger and then you don't use it
every day you're right i mean it's going
to yeah you know
whether or not you should start using it
and then spanish
spanish and italian are are so close to
portuguese and french even you i can
understand most of french
but spanish is easy to understand just
some of their slangs you know like some
of their nouns for certain things like
what the hell is that you know what i
mean are you talking about a bowl of
soup that you've never heard of you know
that kind of stuff we cut off again yeah
yeah yeah i mean honestly
me as an english speaker
uh
other languages that i've tried to learn
um the easiest i have to say was italian
and that might have been because i
already took three years of spanish and
four years of french a long time ago
when i was a child
um so when i tried to learn italian as
an adult i was like oh this is like
super easy
just because a lot of times the word is
very similar to a similar word in
english or a similar word in french or
spanish
and the sentence structure is similar to
what i was familiar with yeah latin
latin sentence structures all the same
that's what well yeah that's that's why
they call them romance languages because
they're all if you once you learn one
and you have things masculine because i
remembered a lot of stuff from french
because i took it for such a long time
in school
um so when i was learning italian i'm
like oh this is like french but easier
it wasn't so much that french was hard
it was the pronunciation i had trouble
with now one of the hardest languages
that i tried to learn and i didn't
really get very far was welsh i did try
to learn like some welsh when i was over
there
but that
what threw me off with welsh i think was
that
a lot of they have
mostly the same letters in the alphabet
but a lot of the letters are pronounced
completely differently than they are in
english and that really throws me off so
like when you see a word the way you
think it's pronounced doesn't sound
anything like the way it's actually
pronounced do you know what i mean so
it's that's kind of like a hard thing to
get past
uh but yeah
so uh dj maniac says at least three of
us in here speak
deutsch german
uh yeah manga said most latin-based
languages are easy to learn yeah i agree
like because and yeah once you learn one
the rules are the same like pretty much
in the other way they almost always have
the same um
um
verbs
verbs are the same
[Music]
yeah that's true you know uh you know so
yeah
uh yeah somebody said uh too many y's in
welsh
jenny did the mutations in welsh throw
you yes that was another thing
is that sometimes depending on which
word was i think this is what you're
talking about if i remember it's been a
long time
sometimes if the word that you were
saying had another word in front of it
that had another letter at the end
sometimes the first letter of that word
would change
you know what i mean
um so i was like how the [ __ ] do you
remember this stuff but honestly from
what i've heard
i'm just happy that i learned english as
a native language because from what i've
heard from non-english speakers that had
to learn it later they were like english
is the very hardest language to learn or
at least one of the hardest i don't know
if it's the hardest chinese would be the
hardest yeah
i guess but yeah but from what i've
heard like at least among non-asian
languages
um that english is very very difficult
to learn so in a way i consider myself
lucky that i don't see why it would be
though just because the word usage might
be weird
yeah maybe well the thing about english
is that because we're such a
conglomeration of [ __ ] from like so many
other languages
it's a very it's a clutch of a language
um which is good in a lot of ways
because it's very dynamic
um because it picks up you know [ __ ]
from wherever it picks up detritus from
wherever it needs to
but
if you don't know english and you're
learning it it's gotta suck
because
what because the rules aren't regular
like we have rules but then there's like
oh and then now here's this list of all
these exceptions to those roles
honestly even people that are native
english speakers their english isn't
that good you know what i mean like i
run into [ __ ] all the time where people
who were born in the united states and
presumably learn to speak english as
their first language uh their writing is
just like grammatically horrific you
know what i mean so it's like obviously
they're not even learning it
right
so
i've heard non-english speakers from
china if i can say some crazy [ __ ]
they're fighting amongst each other
about where who they should learn
english from and they said well the only
real english is like from a certain
place in [ __ ] in england like you
know
you know for outside of london it's a
little tiny [ __ ] dialect they're
talking about some kind of posh twee ass
version
of the english tweet yeah tweet asking
the different versions of the different
dialects of english even in the uk alone
are just all over the [ __ ] board man
a lot of this [ __ ] trash too
the thing about the uk it's it's [ __ ]
trash well the thing about the uk that's
fascinating to me is that the uk
you know it relatively is relatively
small
but
honestly you're in one town yeah you go
a couple miles to another town and it's
the accent is different and you can tell
and they can tell you know they know
exactly where you're from when they hear
you talking it was kind of like that new
england too
yeah well yeah it's similar it's similar
it's always changing yeah and you could
you know it's the same thing in the
south there's different southern dialect
some of its regions some of its [ __ ]
social class
it's going to be different
yeah well and the uk is like that too
right and what's funny is that when
there's these [ __ ] waited zero zeros
are there
i don't know if they can i don't know if
they can hear you
we'll just see if we can get
all right it looks like it's it looks
like it's coming out yeah i've also seen
like so-called what [ __ ] this shit's
[ __ ] falling on me okay
i've seen these so-called linguists
try to [ __ ] properly do a southern
accent that's like you listen to it and
it's [ __ ] an
upper-class
southern accent from 1850 that was only
spoken in like savannah or something you
know
long gone you know and then you go then
you might have to wonder well that might
have been from savannah or that might
have actually just been made up by
hollywood
because
well the thing like i said it's
people's accents are just so even in the
united states i mean here it's probably
i don't think people notices at it as
much because the regions are so much
bigger
but
um you know somebody just said uh that
you know texas accent says oracle texas
accents vary wildly a person from
lubbock sounds nothing like someone from
houston yeah and it's the same kind of
thing and honestly
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm kind
of interested if i went somewhere else
and like what my accent because i don't
think that i had necessarily have a
southern accent even though i'm from
florida and my dad's side of the family
is from tennessee
um
i don't so i don't really know like i
don't
i don't know like it's weird because
when i went to the uk like everybody
knew i was american
but one thing that i got a lot not from
everybody but a lot of people told me
you sound irish yeah they used to say
that to me when i was up in boston to
welsh people i sounded irish yeah which
to me was bizarre because when i because
i know what irish people sound like and
i was like i don't sound anything like
that not to me i don't like to my ears
right now but i don't really know what i
sound like i don't know what my accent
and time affects things too i heard a
recording of a confederate general is an
audio recording of him from uh i guess
his very early 1900s and he was still
alive
and he sounded like
the narrator from fallout
it sounded like transatlantic
yeah which was kind of a big thing
that's kind of what they taught you i'm
assuming like in journalism school or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah yeah there was no
southern drawl
no there was no southern drawl
and we fought the union with all our
hearts
going on in his
and you know there's no southern draw d
that was later dj maniac says the two
accents that have no regional
limitations redneck and gay
yeah
i guess so i guess that's true
i guess that's true yeah but uh yeah i'm
i'm actually fascinated by uh
linguistics and
just differences in accents and stuff
like that i just think that's like
really interesting
uh but yeah so christopher lee uh could
speak
essentially eight languages which you
know makes me feel really really
inadequate right now but you know what i
mean so uh yeah
now uh at this point uh he wasn't he was
really good at that but he wasn't like a
big fan of
school like this particular school
because one of the things was that it
was really and i guess this was pretty
common across the board in british
schools at this point
and then this was a college this wasn't
like a younger kid's school he was still
a teenager though
um very very harsh discipline so they
still like you know beat the crap out of
the students you know when they did
something bad and [ __ ] like that uh so
he hated that
uh he hated they did like weapons
training at the school he wasn't really
into that uh they would do like mock
battles and he said he used to like play
dead just so he didn't have to do it and
all that kind of [ __ ] so he wasn't like
really into it so he left uh his dad
actually ended up going bankrupt in 1939
so he ended up having to leave college
at 17
and he was just kind of like whatever
[ __ ] it so he left
now um at this point
uh you know they're like okay go get a
job
now he's uh it's summertime so a lot of
the kind of nobody's hiring and [ __ ]
like that so uh he couldn't really find
anything
so he ends up going to uh stay with his
sister who was hanging out on the french
riviera i think she was just on vacation
for some period of time
now
this is interesting too like i said it's
almost kind of like this dude's
biography reads like
a novel
you know what i mean because he was like
at these particular places so he's on
the french riviera
he hears
that hey
they're gonna do the last public
execution
in france
um you know what i mean by guillotine
i'm assuming
so he's like it's in paris so he goes
and sees it so he actually saw the last
guillotine execution
in france in paris he was there
um so yeah i mean he wasn't the only one
there was like a [ __ ] ton of people
because obviously he's gonna come see
somebody get beheaded
now uh then he goes to southern france
and he stays with uh an exiled
russian family who were like princes and
[ __ ] so again uh same problem with the
dr kellogg [ __ ] yeah it's green
i'm gonna go get another drink
all right
sorry it's like hopefully you guys
aren't missing anything because usually
i'm watching the
the light
as soon as the light starts turning
other colors other than green i will
usually like stop talking so you guys
don't miss anything
so
and if i think that you missed something
i'll repeat it so
don't worry too much about it i'm just
hopefully you're not worried about it uh
but yeah
tom went to go get a drink in case you
didn't know
so okay so at this point uh you know war
breaks out 1939
so um [ __ ] there it goes again uh come
on come on come on come on
so christopher lee is like uh he was at
this point i think he was still um
under 18
so he couldn't join up with the regular
army
uh because he was too young
so what he did was him and a bunch of
his
similarly aged friends
come on you can do it
oh finland
and they were going to
fight with the russia at the time
and it cut off again
come on
come on
come on oh this is like
come on
okay we back is it back all right
yeah so uh all right where was i cutting
off uh yeah
would you did you hope that like if you
left it would like stop doing it
your [ __ ] masculine energy is like
[ __ ] up my wi-fi yeah
you're blind
you're blocking my wi-fi domineering
pheromones i come in it just [ __ ]
blocks all the goddamn because the
internet waves
he's blocking the internet
you might be i'm not really sure
uh but yeah so um you missed this part
but
uh so at this point like when world war
ii broke out in 1939
um christopher lee wanted to like do
something but at that point he was like
too young to join up in the regular army
because he was still like uh i think he
was only 17 at the time
uh so what he did was him and some of
his friends they went to finland and
they were going to fight
with the finnish army against russia
that's what we're going to do so they
get there and the finnish army is like
well thank you very much for coming we
enjoy your enthusiasm but do you kids
know how to ski
uh and they were like no and they were
like okay well then we can't use you
because
snow y'all so they were like okay well
so they kind of got sent away go back to
england thank you but no
so he goes back to london
and goes back to work as an office clerk
uh so 1940 he's finally age uh he's 18
finally so he joins the home guard
now his dad his original dad not his
stepdad uh jeffrey died at this point
now
what ended up happening though was that
christopher lee i mean his dad was kind
of like a big lieutenant colonel like in
the first world war christopher lee
didn't really seem all that he was like
he admired his dad but he didn't really
want to follow in his footsteps really
but uh he feared that because the war
was you know escalating that he was
going to get
drafted conscripted so he said uh he
joined the royal air force the raf so
that's what he ended up doing
now he got uh his training
and he got stationed to southern
rhodesia
so they sent him out on his first solo
flying mission
and on that first mission he started his
vision started to blur and he started
having like blackouts
so he gets back
and the doctor said your optic nerve is
all [ __ ] up and you should not fly
because you can't really see all that
good
uh and he was really devastated by this
because apparently he'd really enjoyed
uh flying planes and stuff like that
they said yeah it's too dangerous
because you can't really see your optic
nerve is all [ __ ] and they can't fix
it so he didn't uh get to
so he got transferred around uh in
africa with the raf service uh but he
was like i was just kind of like killing
time they didn't really give me anything
to do and he was getting kind of like
bummed out about it
um so finally they put him he was like a
prison warder
uh at salisbury prison in rhodesia
and there from there he got moved to the
suez suez canal zone
and then he got put to work in
intelligence gathering
now during this he was kind of like now
he got killed almost got killed like a
couple of times during this because he
was with the uh number 260 squadron the
raf
and um the germans like bombed the
airfield that he was at
come on
come on you put magic
she's putting magic on it
it it's data's still going it's doing
magic on it yeah i mean i try to keep
talking unless it goes to like zero
let's see like it did just then right it
went to zero for a second it's back yeah
it's a hiccup like that
because it's an [ __ ] and it hates me
i can't really think of a better reason
i don't really know
uh can something happen with hardware
gotta be
yeah you don't know i don't know i don't
know why
i don't know why but yes so just this
does it my tablets don't do it
um all my computers do it do they um
this one which is new
yeah it does
um yes yes sometimes it doesn't
sometimes it doesn't
uh that does it
not to it depends on the day
and that computer is
fairly new
uh my mac does it all the time but my
mac is super old so you know what i mean
uh magic is real
i wish yeah magic's real i hope it is
somebody yes
your name is adriana
she asked if the american accent is
irish uh no not really but this
the southern accent is a mutated irish
accent in some ways which may be
yeah there is some like uh your ethnic
background history to that so maybe
that's what people were when i was in
wales they're hearing that i think
people did hear that because i don't
think i sound irish in this latest when
i was when i was in um
massachusetts
um
non-non-uh
southerners that were up there
thought i was irish because they did
have irish people in the the boston area
they thought i was irish but i was like
no
mississippi mississippi and alabama are
kind of like the south africa of the
united states there's a lot of
there very high numbers of black
populations black people it's kind of
like the same situation where you have
in south africa where you have blacks
[ __ ] afrikaners and [ __ ] boars
white
white southerners are kind of like south
african boars in some ways but
our version of our accent if you
i try to trace it down a lot of it has
to do with you with your with your uh
social class
and your family history
if you descend from sharecroppers you're
going to be speaking kind of
your your accent is going to be a
product of kind of like a mutated
irish accent that's been africanized and
it's because
sharecroppers lived right alongside each
other whether they were white or black
and some of them married each other so
because you then because the south had
later on segregation was a way to try to
reverse the racial interbreeding that
had been going on for centuries there
and once that happened you had special
classes of people people who were red
people who were yellow octoroons
um and it was kind of ended up being
something kind of like out of a damn
feudal japan
you know
it's an aggregation society in it
but you know language went the same way
that's that's i guess it's the best way
to describe it
mcleod 2022 says peter cushing is the
best doctor who uh in case you guys
didn't know peter cushing was actually
played doctor who in two movies
um i've seen doctor who in the daleks i
haven't seen the other one i actually
saw it on rifftrax
he played him as a
human though i thought
and doctor who is like an alien right or
some kind of like interdimensional being
he's from he's and i kind of feel like
when peter cushing played although this
was like fairly early on in the doctor
who
lore i guess so a lot of the rules
haven't been established yet yeah i
don't think his movies are canonical
they're well yeah in the doctor who lore
because and like i said i did watch
doctor who in the and the daleks but um
you know it's a goofy ass movie but i
mean peter cushing i'm gonna watch it
it's peter [ __ ] cushioning right some
of the movies uh were kind of
standalones and they didn't
mesh up with any of the series and they
kind of
you know what i mean they're kind of
like reboots i mean that's okay like i
said it's a fictional character right i
mean do what you want with it it's like
no one's gonna cry um
victor says southern accent is slowed
down british accent you can watch
youtube videos demonstrating this i
should actually watch that because
i've heard that too and like yeah it
could be that too yeah
although although
you have to understand that
if you look at his if you look at
american history
kana there are two things you didn't
want to be and that was this is back in
the 17th and 1800s you didn't want to be
black and you didn't want to be irish
okay
so a lot of the average people that
moved here took on english last names
and tried to anglicanize themselves
as much as possible so it's hard to say
um
i've heard that the mississippian
it was a race war between white people
and
english type scandinavians in the north
and kind of like celtic
and germanic people in the south that
didn't like each other back in the honky
motherland to begin with all right that
was a that was a big factor too
yeah oracle says cushing played him as a
human yes yeah i thought that i mean i
know he did another movie but i haven't
seen that one i've only seen doctors and
alex um and she says but he did bring a
delightful playful energy to the role i
mean
christopher lee and peter cushing i will
watch like shitty ass movies that
they're in um just because
they never phoned it in and they're
always like the best thing in it and he
was definitely the best thing in it even
though that movie was
really not all that good but you know
what i mean
uh okay so
where was i so christopher lee uh as i
said he's uh in number 260 squadron raf
uh the airfield got bombed uh by the
germans
and he almost got killed in that bombing
raid uh also he got malaria quite a lot
uh over 1943 1944
um and had to keep getting uh sent to
the hospital in carthage for treatment
and uh at this point winter 1943
he got there was like an officer swap so
he got seconded to the army because like
i said he was air force
so um
during that time he went he served a
year with the gurkhas the eighth indian
infantry infantry division they were
like rangers yeah and actually did end
up seeing some action in the battle of
monte casino uh again almost died uh
when a plane that he was in crashed on
takeoff when i was in the u.s army we
had our own version of the gurkhas they
were the micronesians
and my in the 506 the unit i was in up
in korea we had like six or seven
micronesians and one of them was gordon
he was a little [ __ ] he ended up
being a ranger sergeant cut a dude's
thumb off in a fight it was [ __ ]
great i think i told that story anyway
but those little micronesians were bad
ass
and the samoans didn't like them they
were constantly fighting each other and
those samoans like we eat those
forget it [ __ ] funny is [ __ ] so you
eat those yeah we eat those little
things
we just pop them in our mouths yeah we
eat those little things like canapes
those island boys man they were bad
asses they were [ __ ] badass my hat's
off to you islanders
including the hawaiians but the [ __ ]
small ones in the [ __ ] and and the
micronesians are always [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] they're all good soldiers though
good soldiers
drinking they [ __ ] lose their minds
but they're good dudes
good fighters
all right so end of 1944 and christopher
lee gets promoted to flight lieutenant
and uh when the war ended in 1945
he actually got a position in the
central registry of war criminals
of security suspects
you know essentially a nazi hunter uh so
what they would do
is uh
you know his [ __ ] was like top secret
obviously
but they would give him like a dossier
and they'd be like this is what the
person did and like this is where we
think they might be and like he had to
like try and go and find them but like
he couldn't really talk about it a lot
so the quote that he gave we were given
dossiers of what they'd done and told to
find them interrogate them as much as we
could and hand them over to the
appropriate authority and then he said
we saw these concentration camps some
had been cleaned up some had not
that's all he would say yeah so again he
was very kind of like but you can like
read between the lines of that kind of
[ __ ] so yeah he was a nazi hunter you
guys
which is uh pretty [ __ ] awesome and
he hasn't even got to like [ __ ]
acting yet
so he leaves the army in 1946
now uh so he gets out and he was gonna
go back to like work in an office and
he's like yeah i don't really want to do
that [ __ ] anymore
um they asked him if he wanted to teach
because like i said he could speak like
a zillion languages and you know he was
all up on his latin and greek and his
classics and stuff and they said do you
want to teach that at university and
he's like i don't really know if i want
to do that either
um he was only 24 at this point
and the story goes that he was having
dinner with uh
his cousin who was the italian
ambassador to england
uh and his
uh cousins looks at him and says have
you ever thought about being an actor
and christopher lee said honestly no
i hadn't really thought about it
um
and then his uncle his cousin says well
maybe you might want to think about it
the weird thing about it is when
christopher lee started out he's like
the more he hadn't really thought about
it prior even though he'd kind of done
it in school
just kind of as a lark
but he's like the more he thought about
the more he kind of liked the idea he's
like when he first started out though
he's like what he used to get all the
time you're too tall to be an actor
because he's six foot five yeah and um i
don't know you could be an actor well it
he's like it did it was an impediment um
but i mean act you know people that
wanted to work with him like would work
around it but they would usually have to
work around it like well you have to sit
the whole time or some [ __ ] like that it
would be [ __ ] like that but he did kind
of the right role
yeah but you know he he did kind of have
problems at first
so uh but like i said he hadn't really
thought about previously but the more he
thought about it the more he was kind of
like yeah that's i kind of like that
idea okay
so he brings it up to his mom the
countess
and the countess is like oh no
cause you know she's a countess we don't
want any actors in our family
i kind of feel like it was probably like
yeah uh and honestly and his mom i maybe
told him this too but they thought maybe
he was not only too tall but too quote
unquote foreign looking even though like
i said to me he doesn't look foreign
in relation to me he doesn't look any
more foreign than i look
um well we come from a background where
there's europeans and all different
that's right maybe because we grew up in
in the united states and i'm just used
to like seeing i mean i'm very tolerant
i went to school even back in the 70s
and 80s with all kind of different kids
and i never even thought about it we
have all these friends we even noticed
that they're laughing that they're latin
we don't even notice sometimes i find
out years later you're like you're
aladdin i didn't know that yeah that
they're like half mexican or something
really i didn't know that well okay it
just never came up we're all in the
we're all in the same scene we're all
listening to the same music we all have
the same culture and listening to the
same music and they're just everybody's
cute so it doesn't it doesn't you don't
even think about it nobody thought about
it never even thought about it it's just
funny and that's kind of like what i
thought about with christopher lee and
like i said same thing with boris
karloff when i found out he was half
indie and i was just kind of like oh it
literally like never occurred to me it
was hey you know when michael from
astoria knight says matt's good to come
hang out with you white people i was
like what
and i'm looking at him i go oh yeah
they're all latins yeah it's like wait
you're not wearing oh yeah that's right
you guys are white too
you're playing white music
they [ __ ] love that [ __ ] though i
guess yeah i don't know it's just funny
but yeah it's just funny that
christopher lee i mean back at that time
uh in the 40s was considered too foreign
looking and also too tall which i get
that because six foot five
that's pretty tall um
so
i can see how like a lot of people
wouldn't want to cast you because
everyone is like a foot shorter than you
are and you know it's going to be like
awkward looking i get that so he said he
did have some problems but you know
people worked around it like i said they
had to like sit him down yeah but you
can also six five you can use that to
your advantage in certain roles well he
did he ended up using that to his
advantage because like i said what do
you want for dracula yeah because look
how [ __ ] imposing he is that's a
scary ass dracula i mean i love bella
lugosi he brought his own like [ __ ]
energy to it yeah but christopher lee i
think was like the scariest dracula
yeah and also kind of the sexiest
dracula
you know bella really he only frank
langella is pretty foxy too but
christopher lee
i don't know i don't know if you could
beat that bella had the voice and the
mannerisms
yeah he had the face
yeah i mean he was good
though though he
i know that they tried to reboot over
and over again him as a dracula as a
[ __ ] dracula knockoff
but i've only seen him as dracula
i haven't seen it in the in the other
movies where he where bella played a
vampire
um there's supposed to be another one's
pretty good where he's got a little
mustache and a goatee it's supposed to
be pretty good but i haven't seen it
which one white zombie is it
no he's a threat he's he's a vampire oh
he did some see they were they had
licensing well he did yeah he did [ __ ]
sounds of other movies i thought well
like no as a vampire
bella lugosi has a vampire they kept
trying to redo that but they had
licensing problems they couldn't call
him dracula they couldn't do a bunch of
[ __ ]
there there's but i heard there's like
one or two out there that he did
that were worthy
fake sequels to dracula have you seen
them
i don't think so i mean about one of
them where he had a little goatee or
something
and he was
they gave him another name like count
something or other but they couldn't use
the word dracula
well yeah that's i mean
yeah it was
it was copyrighted
but the only thing i mean the first
thing that springs to my mind when you
said goatee was white zombie where he
might have been thinking about but he
wasn't a vampire in that he was like a
zombie dude like he had like you know
he made it was like a haitian voodoo
bella did it evidently bella did a
couple more vampire movies but they had
to change up his appearance and they
they couldn't call him dracula and
they're supposed to be pretty good
well i have to look that up because like
i said i mean he was in [ __ ] up the
movies and i can't like remember all of
them yeah i figured you had seen him
i probably did but to be honest with you
i've seen i'm almost 50 years old and
i've seen so many horror movies in my
life that
some of them like blend together
especially
what the [ __ ]
i wish you could take the camera and
just show them [ __ ]
yeah
with their legs like
sticking up in the air and [ __ ]
since she's looking at me well yeah
we're talking about you
she knows when you're talking about her
she's like later with a little belly
sticking out and her little back legs
look out like different colors why it
didn't turn red there it is
it must be back yeah what's up hulk
you you're [ __ ] crazy yes you are
insane
she is kind of crazy yeah she's crazy so
i guess we're back yeah we are i think
so all right uh so yeah
obviously like i said mom's a countess
she's like i don't want any actors in my
family that's like i don't know if she
said this but she was like
that's kind of like lower class you know
what i mean too foreign looking too tall
uh all this other kind of [ __ ] but
she like bitched about it so much
apparently that christopher lee was like
well i'm going to do it just by you know
i don't know
i don't know if he said it like that but
you know he was just kind of like well
now i really want to do it because you
keep like [ __ ] [ __ ] on me about
it uh so he actually ends up
at the end of 1946
uh he he joins like a
uh an acting company
so uh or an acting school of some type
so he spends the next couple of years
like learning acting uh and he did like
a lot of [ __ ] around you know he kind of
worked his way up he would do [ __ ] like
uh you know
keeping the theater stage like sweeping
it
um you know actors that were on stage he
would hold up their cue cards he would
do that kind of [ __ ]
and so eventually they started giving
him like little parts in some of the
plays and [ __ ] like that
jenny is a praying mantis while frozen
oh it must have frozen when i was going
like that like what pookie was doing
all right
uh now just as his mother said
um
his height did actually kind of work
against him to a degree because like i
said six five is pretty [ __ ] tall
um
so you know like i said casting
directors are like ah you know we kind
of like you but you're a little tall but
they like i said they had to work around
it
so uh so he would have to like sit down
and give his lines and [ __ ] like that um
he started out as a lot of actors do
like his early roles uncredited
and some of them he was in some [ __ ] and
films and then they would cut it out
later
but you know that's kind of how it goes
when you're making your mark i guess
his film debut was actually in 1947
in a movie called
corridor of mirrors
and uh in this movie
he played a guy named charles
and the director
uh
got around how tall he was
by sitting him down through the whole
entire scene
in a nightclub so he wouldn't look
taller than the other actors that he was
talking to
what happened i'm going to make
something a moderator
who's that keith
i called him keith
okay i can't do it here okay well you
just could have just told me to do it
uh add moderator there you go got it all
right all right all right there you go
there you go murder harness then you
went right again yeah because we [ __ ]
with it [ __ ] that [ __ ] up we just
messed up we messed with the juju is
that what it is i guess i don't really
know i don't really know i'm just i'm
hoping that it doesn't like cut off to a
point where i have to like do another
part because that's a pain in the ass
um
so yeah so he's in this movie uh he had
a one line in that movie uh and he had
to sit down the whole time but you know
that was his film debut so you know
uh he was also in captain horatio
hornblower uh in 1951
played a spanish captain because he
could speak spanish and fence which is
all the director cared about and he's
like okay you're in so that's what he
did
uh he was also in quo vadis from 1951
although he was uncredited
that was shot in rome
and uh during the 1950s
from you know early 50s onwards next
decade or so
he was in about 30 movies although he
usually played background characters
kind of action stock action characters
that type of thing
uh he also had some other early roles
and this is kind of where we're getting
into
him and peter cushing's
careers overlapping because
some some of his
hey
it's a it's a friendship
it's beautiful it's lovely
um i'm kind of running out of drink are
you gonna
your shit's almost empty yeah but yeah
so uh some of these early roles uh that
he was in were also
early roles for peter cushing although
in their very early uh movies they
weren't really
in the same movie in the sense that they
were like in
so the first of these was actually the
very famous
uh hamlet
uh from 1948 the lawrence olivier
oscar-winning adaptation of hamlet uh
both christopher lee and peter cushing
were in this
although both of them as i said were
minor roles and i don't believe they met
each other on set i don't even know if
they were on you know they were there on
the same day or whatever
um both of them were also in a movie
called moulin rouge in 1952.
christopher lee actually played uh
george serrat who the artist and uh
peter cushing played another character
who was like a fictional character
because like i said that was kind of
based around you know toulouse-lautrec
and all those kind of artists uh at the
time going on around uh the moulin rouge
and all the kind of absinthe houses back
then in paris and uh so he played a
fictional character in that and
christopher lee was also in it as well
uh they were also both in a movie called
alexander the great from 1956.
now
right here in 1957
this is kind of where christopher lee's
and peter cushing's
legends i guess began and were cemented
1957
christopher lee uh gets hired by hammer
film productions which is kind of like
new at the time
and
what they were going to do
uh
was they were trying to do a
more modern interpretation of mary
shelley's frankenstein they want to do
it in color they wanted to do
gore and all kind of this kind of stuff
it was like a new thing they were going
to do with it they were kind of playing
on the universal stuff but they wanted
to like update it for the modern era
so uh christopher lee
got cast as the monster because
obviously because he's six foot five
now i think there were some kind of
legal issues i guess with universal who
i guess at that point still sort of
loki had the rights to
uh the frankenstein monster and for real
like the um the jack pierce makeup with
the iconic boris karloff makeup with the
square head and the bolts and everything
uh that was copyrighted so they couldn't
use that
so actually uh christopher lee appearing
as the monster in the 1957 one looks
more
zombie-like i guess or like monster-like
than
the more stylized uh universal one oh we
went down to zero again
so this first movie uh in which lee
played the monster
was called the curse of frankenstein
now peter cushing also cast as
dr frankenstein in this
and this was actually the movie on which
they met one another
now the story goes christopher lee said
this in his uh biography i think
so they're both on the set of the curse
of frankenstein this is a new uh studio
hammer films this was uh you know i
don't think it was their first film but
you know they were very new as a studio
and so christopher lee
comes in
and he says this is a quote our very
first encounter
began with me storming into his dressing
room and announcing in petulant tones i
haven't got any lines because he was the
monster
he meaning peter cushing looked up his
mouth twitched and he said dryly you're
lucky i've read the script
at which point they became
pretty much friends for life and it was
friends for life because they were
actually like best friends until peter
cushing died in 1984. so i [ __ ] loved
that story how they met each other
um that's so [ __ ] cute
i mean
the thing about playing frankenstein's
monster because i think i you know i
don't know how true this is but i know
in ed in tim burton's ed wood they kind
of like talked about how bella lugosi
didn't want to play frankenstein's
monster because
you know oh there's no lines it's all
grunting and blah blah blah
and
oh yeah damn motorcycle all right done
whatever showing off um
but um you know so it was kind of a
thing where you know christopher lee had
been in you know 40
something movies at this point and he's
like now i'm playing frankie's ass
monster i'll get his talk
and he was kind of upset about it uh
clearly
but
i don't know there's but the thing about
playing the monster though and i know in
the novel he talks but they don't
usually do that in the movies so i do
kind of feel like there is something
about
physicality though and honestly
i don't know i'm not an actor but i kind
of feel like it would be more of a
challenge because there's a lot of [ __ ]
you have to convey without saying
anything language and like facial
expressions and [ __ ] like that so i
would just i don't know i would kind of
like think of it as a challenge but i
can see how a lot of actors be like yeah
i don't even get to talk and that sucks
but you know
uh went down to zero again
oh that tastes like tequila oh did i get
a ticket
i probably gave you tequila that's
tequila
i'll take it oh
yeah they gave you tequila that was
awful
it's all right
almost outside he made me a drink
i just drank it i was like oh my god
that's tequila
oh my god i hate tequila but uh yeah
he's
uh he's only had one well i thought he'd
only have one drink but i guess he's had
more than that
uh but yeah so they met on the curse of
frankenstein super cute uh and their
friendship like lasted forever
uh so yeah
and honestly like christopher lee goes
on to say like after he said that about
uh peter cushing saying yeah you're
lucky i've read the script you're lucky
you don't have any lines uh and
christopher lee says it was a typical
wry comment i soon found peter was the
great perfectionist who learned not only
his own lines but everybody else's as
well
but with all had a gentle humor which
made it quite impossible for anybody to
be pompous in his company
and one thing and everybody that works
with peter cushing said this nobody ever
said a bad word about the dude not that
not that i could find
um they never said that he was difficult
or anything like that but they said that
he was very much a perfectionist and
that he was very
the worst thing i saw thank you that i
saw uh said about him was that he was a
quote unquote fuss pot
in the sense that he was just very uh
meticulous
about his own costuming about his own
lines and because he learned everybody
else's lines and he learned everything
else too he would give like
uh
not he would give advice about like oh
let's do this with the costumer let's do
that with the costume and stuff like
that but he was so nice about it that
nobody really seemed to have like felt
like he was stepping on their dicks or
anything but he was just wanted this
[ __ ] to be as good as it could be
and he seemed like very good at
conveying that to people without seeming
um arrogant or like he was telling
people their job or anything he was just
like giving people like advice you know
what i mean
but like i said nobody i couldn't find
anybody that said a bad word about the
dude it was funny him or christopher lee
honestly no it's funny what's that those
those um ice makers that we got they're
like becoming a thing
a dude that i subscribed to that just
moved here in florida he's a big [ __ ]
big youtuber he's got millions of
followers he says yeah i'm sitting there
drinking my tequila in miami with my ice
maker going
see he had to be talking about the same
thing
people are buying ice makers
i didn't even honestly it's a good idea
i mean i'm probably like slow on the
uptake but because i never thought about
it i didn't even know that they made
those that's a good idea until recently
because i'm like oh yeah duh i guess
instead of having to go down to the
refrigerator they make everything
nowadays you just got [ __ ] in a little
box that sits there and if you pour
water in it it just [ __ ] makes ice i
mean as soon as i get up in the morning
i get up at like 6 30 seven o'clock once
and i pour water and turn it on i got
ice all [ __ ] day i got ice water i
can have iced coffee that's all i that's
all i ever director of the day honestly
yeah ice cream ice makers are a thing
man they're the ice makers are a thing
now
they're not expensive i mean i'm too
lazy to go all the way downstairs
we have the fridge that makes ice but
i'm too lazy to go for 90 bucks you can
have a [ __ ] ice maker and pretty
colors right there you just
although i'm still mad that you didn't
get the red one i'm gonna get another
i'm gonna get a red one because look i
love red yeah we're gonna get a red one
this isn't my real hair yeah we'll
retire that one for party duty
so if we have a party we'll [ __ ] set
them up and they'll just have
[ __ ] making ice one of these days we
need to have a party yeah that's why we
will when this house is kind of
furnished which it's not well there's
more stuff we gotta buy yeah i mean this
room is furnished yeah but that's
because
yeah this is the room where we work
that's where it's gonna be on camera so
i wanted it to look good so i did this
[ __ ] first once we get enough super
chats to furnish the place we'll have a
[ __ ] seriously the bedroom we'll
bring we'll bring zach the bedroom has a
bed
a tv
and a tiny little thing in the corner
that has like cat treats and things on
it that's it yeah that's all we don't
have any art in the walls we haven't
painted it nothing that's like it's so
abandoned i gotta paint it first
well that's why i got you that that's
why i got you that gift card to buy
paint uh yeah but we need to replace
some [ __ ] um well you don't have to
buy paint with that i just said
okay you can buy something all right
let's go go get some blinds
we need two blinds but uh no i had tila
and her husband over here
everybody can come over and that well
all our goth friends will be here and
it'll be a big [ __ ] orgy we should
have one big [ __ ] rager
everybody will plan for it for like six
months yeah we'll invite like all our
friends locally that we know we'll
invite all you guys that can get down
here yeah and it'll be like a whole
we're gonna have to be like super right
we're gonna bring all these damn cam
girls some porn stars over here
we're gonna have to like put a bouncy
castle in the yard
i don't know
yeah
we'll have some bands show up
and tear this place up they were pretty
good last time we had them over though
they didn't trash the place
i was actually shocked yeah
we haven't had a party in a while yeah
but honestly our friends still talk
about the party that we had how many
years ago was that
four or five years ago that was a while
back yeah and people still talking about
that and
yeah and when we told them oh we just
bought a new house and they're like a
party party yeah and yeah remember that
last one you had i was like dude that
was like years ago yeah but they're
still like talking about it but i have
to say that even like a lot of people
came to that party well we had an agent
a smug machine we had people would like
who were you we had people like show up
we didn't know who they were yeah then
we had a dj we had a smoke machine we
had [ __ ] like yeah people were there
until like i leave we have people there
until like
morning and we were just kind of like
okay well you have to go now because i
had an indian buffet going yeah
but some of it was vegan they were
tearing that when everybody left finally
yeah i was like
wow this house is like surprisingly not
trash nothing was broken yeah uh the
only thing you know we just had to clean
up like you know plastic cups and [ __ ]
and the only thing that was dirty was
people like tracking dirt in from like
outside because they went out on the
patio smoke pot or whatever and they
would like you know track dirt in but
that was it
nothing was broken nobody like [ __ ]
anything up nothing all goth dudes and
[ __ ] bands and porn stars
misfit toys was here
all their [ __ ] stripper girlfriends
were here
everybody was oh they were all here well
not here but at our old house in the old
place yeah everybody was there yeah it
was it was good night
i mean that was everybody that was a
really really fun i had little swallows
a bodyguard that was a really good i was
trying to kick that dude out a little
small [ __ ] bag no no no you getting
the [ __ ] out of you getting the [ __ ] out
of here
well cuz some people came and we're like
well and some people came that we didn't
know who they were because some people
apparently just heard about it or showed
up right like that was like a friend of
a friend and they heard about it they
turned like you know any party so they
turned up but yeah but
honestly we didn't have to kick anybody
out really i had to turn down at least
20 people yeah i was like nah
sorry man you're not cool enough
that's not what i told them but that's
what it was
because the [ __ ] you know what i mean
we had about 40 or 50 people over
so you
you got limited space you can't keep an
eye on everybody
yeah you don't know what they're up to
it's like are they [ __ ] trash in my
shoes there's like some [ __ ] and drugs
in my house boogie nights thank you tila
thank you you're giving a party who are
your two dream guests this is for the
challenge you and your husband are our
dream guests i'm gonna have you all show
up here that would be your husband show
up that would be and you're gonna have a
florida party mango says i'd fly over
from the uk for that party yeah okay all
right
come on now and then no need for me too
says i'd love to do a road trip out to
you guys i can do it if you plan it out
far enough yeah give me a year and i'll
help bankroll it we've already had you
know what we should do we've already had
people want to meet us up at the club
that says look when you're in florida
he's going to be here soon i said when
you're in florida give me a heads up and
i'll i'll meet you you know his
girlfriend you know what we should do
i know it's in a monster march
but it'll it'll be here before we know
it
we should have
the world ending halloween party
that'll give everybody like time to
prepare give me time to prepare give
everybody time because the house will be
ready by then
that's halloween though it's like a few
i mean you know it's already march which
doesn't i mean it seems like a long time
till halloween because it's really it's
man i gotta paint this place with some
furniture i gotta buy
um
maybe
gotta finish i mean we could like
you know it looks good in here
the the the front they get the cement
poured out there i want to repaint that
driveway
i'm gonna put that [ __ ] in some [ __ ]
black latex or [ __ ] gray latex
or something i don't like that bare
concrete out there i want that [ __ ]
looking classy i don't love it either
but like i said i don't really want to i
don't know it's going to be really
expensive like that driveway is so
long and it would be nice to have a
couple of [ __ ] um like you said kind
of like hide a beds like that in here i
did buy it's not a hide-a-bed but it's a
it's like a leather or like a vinylish
couch it's not super comfortable but you
can sleep on it if you have if we have
people coming here from another i just
bought that 240 if we have people coming
here from other countries or other
states if it gets out of that we're
gonna let you all stay here come here
early
get ready for the party and then uh you
guys can crash here you know and then
you might be here for a couple days if
it gets down to that
so um you know and you gotta have a
place for y'all to stay i don't want to
spend
you guys spending [ __ ] 125 a night at
some of these hotels around here but
well this place is bad there aren't any
there aren't any hotels around here no
there are i mean it's up at up into the
town over there and they're uh in mount
dorado dora and they're expensive mount
dora is uh a british style
well it's kind of like a lot of people
like to go there to like antique and
stuff i kind of feel like that's what
mount dora is known for it's not that
far from here it's only looking you can
go look on google earth and look at
mount dora and we're not horribly far
from downtown sanford yeah although
downtown san diego doesn't really have
anything to plan that [ __ ] out for a
time where there's club events and the
party and all that [ __ ] is packed within
about four or five days you i'm talking
about
so we have like a week of it
that's what you do well that's what i'm
saying if you're gonna do that we're
staring
a vacation destination where you got a
starry night playing live maybe what you
call it
you know what i mean we have star night
coming at uh
wheels pub
and then a club night
and then a party night
and then something else and then and
then they can go and hear see that's why
i'm saying around halloween because
there's always good [ __ ] going on around
we'll see i'm just saying and that gives
us some time the stars have to align
we'll see
but like i said i mean we had like an
epic [ __ ] party in our old place yeah
and this place is like 50 bigger yeah we
have so many more rooms no it's 100
bigger
it's twice the size it's not choices
that's not always the size it's
the size and a half bigger
yeah
okay it's 50 bigger okay i figured it
out i'm getting it all right
uh what about a holiday in express
they got them around here they got [ __ ]
like do they have some like up in here
i kind of feel like the closest one
would probably be mount dora i think
mount dora has some help
and some bed and breakfast because a lot
of people go there to like uh for
antiquing and whatnot just look at mount
dora florida [ __ ] google sessions
fairly close yeah it's nice it's nice
that's fairly close yeah um
or sanford is fairly close as well and
there's an airport in sanford yeah which
is not horribly yeah you don't fly into
orlando fly indoor sanford it's much
better if you can it's much
uh i don't know if it's cheaper but it's
easier no it is cheaper
sometimes it's depending on where you're
coming from depending on where you come
from yeah but we did usually advise
people please fly into sanford it's a
private it's almost kind of like that
that's where the rich people fly because
it's very small very small and it's and
it's still an international airport kind
of deal
um you usually have to get um
a transfer through like through atlanta
yeah because atlanta is kind of like the
main hub in this part of the country
but
and i think that a couple times when i
was looking for a cheaper flight to new
york city
i flew from
sanford to atlanta and then to new york
and it was actually cheaper than flying
out of orlando and it was like
easier because sanford like i said it's
much much smaller there's only one
terminal
um
it's not overcrowded the orlando airport
while not obviously the same uh size as
atlanta or london or denver or some
other airports i've been to that are a
[ __ ] nightmare orlando airport is
still kind of a [ __ ] nightmare yeah
no tila i'm not gonna ass kissing she
says tom's a great asking no
you and your husband come down here you
and your big old [ __ ] six foot
something old white husband come here
and [ __ ] we're gonna get this [ __ ]
it's gonna i'm gonna get that [ __ ] on
video there's going to be some
interracial [ __ ] going on in the house
it's going to be a [ __ ] he's going to
install video cameras throughout the
whole year
it's going to be a whole
you're essentially assigning a privacy
waiver
semi-drug induced [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh dance orgy
okay
we're [ __ ] it's gonna be it's hot the
last [ __ ] party was very hot it was
very hot
yeah y'all y'all enjoy it that was a
good party but people [ __ ] in their
20s 30s 40s and 50s they're all [ __ ]
cool just like some [ __ ] from [ __ ]
it's like some [ __ ] out of the movies
the last one was like some [ __ ] out of
the movies the [ __ ]
the neighbors like what the [ __ ] is
going on i had i had dimitri here yeah
djs and [ __ ] dj lights yeah kind of
[ __ ] i had dimitra here from [ __ ]
eyebar [ __ ] banging late a laser
light system and a smoke machine and a
smoke was [ __ ] sitting on the smoke
alarm [ __ ] going out the front door
into the damn [ __ ] lawn and [ __ ] and
all our [ __ ] high caliber neighbors
at that last one like what the [ __ ] is
going on there and i'm like hey man the
pakistanis had a wedding last week
and that [ __ ] was [ __ ] off a chain so
we're partying here this is some this is
some guy though like our neighbors were
pretty cool yeah they were cool nobody
called the cops no nobody it was yeah
well our neighbors at that time right
they had some a lot of parties when
you're in these little enclosed
communities
these little florida enclosed
communities
that they're very uh [ __ ] um
forgiving of the neighbors you know i
mean you're all in the same homeowners
association and i joined the facebook
and the facebook group for the place and
they know that we're here
you know you know they got [ __ ]
fitness checks in here [ __ ] bumping
steroids and selling [ __ ] fitness
programs right here in this thing they
got an ifbb bodybuilder [ __ ] chick in
here
trying to sell her [ __ ] over the [ __ ]
black bear i was gonna i want to say uh
thank you next dimension media gave us a
gave us a super chat would love
halloween party i drive down from
atlanta for that hopefully tom will
think i'm cool enough to let in oh no it
would yeah for real now if you're a
listener if my sister lives in atlanta
by the way i make reservations if you're
a listener and i make reservations then
you can come you guys are cool if you're
gonna come yeah
i mean you're here so obviously you're
cool enough to like be here we've been
doing this show for years
yeah since yeah
2016. the thing is summer of 2016 we
started doing the show the thing is
though it has changed a lot since then
but yeah we've been doing it since the
thing is though is it would have to be
off a chain type of [ __ ] situation
where it's going to go on for [ __ ]
four or five or six days well that's
what i'm saying if people are going to
come from everywhere then you guys are
going to see everything then it's going
to be like a whole experience right
we're going to go out and go meet the
[ __ ] so we have to hold havoc
and then you're going to go to the
[ __ ] sure and i'll introduce you to
big tom we'll go to mannequins
um because eye bar is gone that that
shit's closed well they're moving it
yeah
um
i heard what they were moving it but i'm
not allowed to say that
yeah i'm not going to say
but
it'll be all right i think it'll be all
right
but yeah well somebody asked i think on
our last on our yesterday uh matinee
somebody said well how was the
night that we went out because remember
like after the sidetrack show we went
out it was huge
yeah it was fun although honestly i
drank so much on the show yeah
i got there i had one drink oh he taught
me the mannequins yeah and then i made
anna just give me water the rest of the
night yeah and i started getting tired
once i got there i was like get out of
here well yeah because i felt kind of
like tired on the way there because i'm
like man i'm already kind of tired and
kind of drunk and i was like i kind of
want to go but blah blah blah and then
we went and i was like man i don't feel
that good but then like when we got
there
like the music was really good i'm like
all right i'm into my friends weren't
there well some of them some of them
but it was still like fun like the music
was good but i could only drink like one
i drank one jack and coke like barely
like i kind of just sipped at it and i
was just kind of like just keep the
water coming i just drank water all
night the thing is about driving here
from a place like atlanta
if you actually [ __ ] divvied up what
it would cost you in gasoline
you could probably fly here cheaper
it depends like i said oh no you can fly
here or cheaper i think gasoline is
[ __ ] almost three three something a
gallon and
um you could probably fly into sanford
you could if you did it right if you
did it way in advance
if we had a date did it a couple months
in advance
um
like i did to my dad's place i think i i
did round trip from here to mississippi
was only like [ __ ] 200 bucks
wasn't it
200. it was pretty cheap i was like 100
each
yeah i remember like booking you that
flight right because we booked it like
the day that you got that phone call
yeah it was like a hundred dollars each
way
and i think it was 130 something was it
130 each something like that each way or
round trip
no i think that was the wrong trip
there's no way you could drive it for
that cheap
holy [ __ ]
okay what was that thank you no need for
me too here's another vote for world
ending get together if y'all in a year
or so i'll bring the herb okay thank you
very much tony tony c
just sent us a hundred dollar that
shit's red it's red i've never seen red
is that time i thought something was
like dangerous tony is that or is that
an error was that supposed to be ten
dollars holy [ __ ] god damn we'll set it
back i'm having a flashback too
do you remember like you guys know we
love dan bell yeah dan bell
one time
somebody sent him 500
mistakenly yeah and he felt so bad and
like she was like oh [ __ ] i meant to
send you like five dollars i guess or 50
i don't know or something and she
accidentally sent 500
um
don't super chat when you're drunk
and uh you know we've all been guilty of
it i've been there
but you know what i mean so he was like
there was this whole saga about him like
trying to get her her money back because
um a long time to do it well the thing
about it is like super chats you don't
get them immediately you get them um
i don't know if you guys know but if you
have a
a youtube channel you get them the same
time that you get your google adsense
money
so it usually just comes in one big bulk
uh you know payment on
uh the 21st of the month they usually
send it so it's
all the people that clicked on your ads
or interacted with your ads or whatever
and all your super chats come in on the
21st so if somebody sent you a super
chat you don't actually get it until the
21st of the following month
so he was trying to explain that to her
yeah and she was like oh [ __ ] and she
seemed to like realize at the time and i
was like oh my god i felt so bad for
like everyone involved but holy crap if
that was legitimate
thank you
thank you you are awesome
uh that's the first time that that's
ever happened and i was like freaking
out because i was like why is it red
it's red because that usually means
something bad i usually mean something
bad
um
yeah no need for me too says they're so
drunk that they haven't noticed see see
that's what i'm worried about
because honestly
i've done some [ __ ] on live i've ordered
[ __ ] online we've all ordered [ __ ]
online
when we're drunk that we didn't mean to
order well i haven't but some people
have
[Laughter]
i don't know who tony is
tony just jumps out of nowhere
everybody's going oh [ __ ] damn
yeah damn did you see that
i mean because tony's like nah man
no man it's not is it good i guess you
know is it okay yeah that's all right
tony's a high roller bro okay so you
just jump in the chat chat we don't even
know who tony is he's like jumping in
the chat in the shot i said it with the
seat in the chat oh i thought you were
talking about like william shot just
jumps in the chat
with [ __ ] a hundred dollars out of
nowhere getting the [ __ ]
attention i mean that's pretty awesome
thank you very much thank you very much
that's the biggest super chat we've ever
had yeah i mean for real because i've
been listening since 2018 before the gay
pope when tom was really really quite in
the background
you kept me company when i worked late
in my cabinet shop for many of the years
okay thank you tony oh my god that's
awesome yeah well you're you're a
long-term listener that was back with
[ __ ] agp was um
agp look
agp and i we're friends on facebook and
that [ __ ] is always jumping in tom you
know if you were gay you'd be on
testosterone and i keep talking about
that
because it just tells me that you know
tom you're getting probably hot but if
you were really [ __ ] hot you'd be on
a test like [ __ ] get the [ __ ] and i
just i block him okay i [ __ ] i i
silence his ass on facebook because if
he really knew it was up he would know
that not only i'm on testosterone i'm on
[ __ ] steroids
so you know what i mean like what the
[ __ ] is he still messaging you about
that yeah it's like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you're not following
all right
i'm double dipping
it's not just [ __ ] well it's not just
[ __ ]
we love aj yeah it's not just tess this
[ __ ]
he's been on our show how many times has
he been on our show three times three
times three times well like i said we'll
have him back on eventually we should
because
he's been on all of our shows talking
about scientology yeah which you know
because
he's an expert on that i'm very
interested in that because i worked for
scientologists back in the day uh in
case you guys didn't know
and
i don't i'm not super a fan of like
having guests on the show but because
that's why we've only had a couple but
honestly he's always a good time yeah
having him on the show he's funny he's
just that he is very funny [ __ ] is
[ __ ] very [ __ ]
pope centric he only worries about
himself
and he's he's not [ __ ] paying
attention i said tell me i said [ __ ]
atp
[ __ ] you talking about man [ __ ] he's
not paying attention you know he's not
paying attention
i'm on hrt i'm all test and i do do my
very mild
steroid
cycles for therapeutic reasons i'm not
trying to get [ __ ] huge
like an ifbb bodybuilder or anything
that's not really good for your health
it's just
i'm going to get up to a certain size
and i'm just going to maintain that and
uh it has to do with life extension more
than anything else
lifespan extension like that chinese guy
that i showed you he's [ __ ] 72 years
old
[ __ ] looks fantastic that's all
i want to do
i want to make it into my late 70s and
[ __ ] die strong that's
and looking good that that's all i care
about
if i die at [ __ ] 78 but i [ __ ]
look had a [ __ ] good time i'm strong
looking and
healthy then
energy then i'll i'll do a trade-off
but according to what i'm seeing the
anecdotal evidence
looking at guys like jacqueline and
some of these other guys
i am of a certain type where this is
something i can do
to extend my
life span and life quality
with uh therapeutic
cycles of
things that have been around since the
50s you just
it's out there people
do do your homework
okay
john robertson says
hey tom and jenny love the show topic me
too
i always wanted to be an actor with the
manners of peter cushing the badassness
of christopher lee yeah and the acting
quality of vincent price love you guys
thank you honestly
one of the
best things to me
finding out later in my life was that
all three of those guys were like
friends in real life
that just like
it warmed my heart i don't know it just
it really does i love all those guys and
it's just that's so [ __ ] awesome
so where were we we're talking about
curse of frankenstein like i said this
is where
the first hammer film
that
christopher lee and peter cushing were
in together and this is where they met
each other
and as i said this is kind of like where
their uh friendship store sort of
started out
now
this movie uh very very successful
for hammer so obviously this is what
audience wanted wanted to see this is
an update of the universal monsters
of a classic horror but with a more
modern twist more gory more boobs
because you know that was what hammer
was known for
so you know so they wanted to go more in
that direction
um so basically
they're kind of like okay at this point
they did
that and they're like okay well now we
want to do
dracula
so at this point
1958 they do dracula now as i said i
think in the uk
this movie is just known as dracula
in the us
and
everywhere i've seen it it's known as
horror of dracula
just to differentiate it from the other
adaptations
but horror of dracula came out in 1958
and at this uh point lee is playing
obviously uh his first turn as count
dracula
and peter cushing his first turn as van
helsing
and everybody was so
into that
which
even now this many decades later
if i had been alive at that point holy
[ __ ] i could have seen it those two
every time they're in a movie together i
[ __ ] love it i love it
i don't give a [ __ ] what the movie is
about i want to see the two of them like
interacting and it's so funny
that
i was watching like cinemassacre they
did like a movie massacre a movie
monster thing about this and they were
kind of like peter cushing versus
christopher lee and they're like they
pointed out they said
peter cushing essentially made an entire
career out of kicking christopher lee's
ass because he always played like the
villain he always played like
you know and uh
and it's so funny that they played that
so well even though they were like best
friends in real life
i don't know that's like very very funny
to me but yeah so that happened
so
horror of dracula comes out in 1958
first time christopher lee plays dracula
first time
uh peter cushing plays van helsing
and
honestly at this point christopher lee
is
36 years old
um
peter cushing i think was a bit older
a couple years older hold on one second
what's that somebody's saying asking
women hold on why does testosterone
equal gay
well it doesn't okay
it doesn't equal good it's just you have
to understand something all right i got
to pee though i'm good
um
a certain kind
i don't want to say there's a certain
kind there there are many gay men
that um have an appreciation for uh the
masculine qualities okay
and uh
it's kind of a situation where the more
masculine dude is the more they're into
it
so it's kind of a glorification of of
maleness
so
um
they start working out they start
getting bigger they start uh [ __ ]
trying to get bigger than [ __ ] a
[ __ ] normally would be would
want to get big or they try to want to
get bigger than is possible especially
after the age of 40 and they start
bumping a lot of tests
they like that [ __ ]
freaky [ __ ]
muscular look
for them it's a
[Music]
it's a it's it's kind of like a [ __ ]
glorification of masculinity
it also exists in the [ __ ]
female world you know what i mean they
got lesbians out there that like [ __ ]
super super female looking women with
gigantic implants and
you know um you know like the [ __ ] i
mean extreme basketball implants they
got lesbians that like that
um especially overseas not so much in
the west but
from what are some friends of mine tell
me a lot of these like chinese and
japanese type girls that have those
gigantic implants like that that's
actually the lesbians
so
it's like that
and
guys that get really [ __ ] jacked
are kind of the equivalent to the girls
that get gigantic implants it's similar
okay good
man thank you
just to answer this question
uh so yeah
honestly like i said christopher lee the
first time he plays dracula in horror of
dracula 1958
um
iconic role
but
uh because he was so good at it
he got a little bit typecast and i feel
like he was a little bit upset about it
but
i mean you know he still like [ __ ]
did it
but there was a whole kind of thing
about it like i said he was 36 at the
time
um and he said the quote being
it bought me it brought me a name a fan
club and a secondhand car
for all of which i was grateful so like
i said
he seemed to have like just wanted to do
it for a job at first and then
you know i guess he was worried about
being typecast as a lot of actors are
but
because he didn't really he was
reluctant to get back to it but he was
such a good [ __ ] dracula i'm just
saying
uh so again both a blessing and a curse
um
they did ask him as i mentioned earlier
they made hammer made a whole bunch of
dracula movies
every single time that they made another
dracula movie after the first one they
were like we already told everybody
christopher lee that you were gonna be
dracula in this movie
and
all of the people that are all the other
actors and crew that are working on this
movie
won't get a job now because you didn't
agree to it so
he said later jokingly that he got
emotionally blackmailed into like doing
a lot of these movies but
you know what are you gonna what are you
gonna do
so he actually ended up playing dracula
10 times
uh not real
i mean
to be honest with you like i said
earlier
some people have argued that like gary
oldman was the sexiest dracula i'm not
gonna shut up
yeah that was a good that was a good one
i'm not gonna like if and if people have
a different opinion this is all
subjective
i think to me christopher lee
i think was the sexiest dracula but
that's me
um
in the sense that he was the most
menacing he was the most imposing
um he had the least
romantic pretensions
i guess if you want to say it like that
because i do kind of feel like the gary
oldman one they they went like in a more
romantic direction i kind of liked the
christopher lee one
where he was like clearly villainous but
also still kind of sexy like despite
yourself
like this is obviously not something you
want to get involved with because he's a
monster i haven't but still
but still
yeah you know what i mean i gotta see it
and i kind of feel like that to me
that's like the essence of dracula to me
is that you know this is like an evil
monster
and yet
you can't help yourself cause holy [ __ ]
you know what i mean
to me that's like the essence of dracula
and honestly like i know it's different
from the original novel where he was
kind of
ugly
he was more like nosferatu looking
or rat like yeah um
and
different from the more romantic
portrayals which i would call the bella
of the gossip portrayal a more romantic
betrayal
um
[Music]
but christopher lee's was still
sexy but unromantic
and i kind of like liked that about it
and i think that was like
the different thing that he brought to
that role actually and i think that's
why a lot of people uh think that he was
prop maybe the best dracula but like i
said that's subjective
it depends on what you're uh looking at
i do
i don't know i don't know if there's the
best dracula because i said like what
what are you focusing on
there's a bunch of different ones that's
what i'm saying yeah that's what i'm
saying i mean uh that dracula what was
that one that [ __ ] uh came from it's
more recently called dracula untold or
dracula unleashed
that was that newer one what was that
called oh right it was good um yeah i
liked that as well i don't remember who
played dracula in that though who the
[ __ ] was that it was totally different
it's the same guy the same guys it did
like 300 yeah yeah that same studio i
liked that as well yeah i think it's
called dracula untold yeah that's what
it's called and it showed why vlad
became a vampire so he could save
wallachia from the [ __ ] on oncoming
assault from the
from from uh from the from a muslim army
remember that from uh yeah
and uh he was doing [ __ ] out on the
battlefield but he had to become a
vampire to do that that was another good
story
there are many good dracula stories
that's what i'm saying is the same well
that's why it's hard for me to pick like
best dracula because it's like i'm like
well what angle are you coming in from
dracula
you know if you're saying like what's
most faithful to the novel
probably the francis ford coppola one is
most faithful than
maybe yeah but i well the francis ford
coppola one mixed with nosferatu
because i do kind of feel like nosferatu
even though it's not allowed to be
called dracula because of copyright
issues
that's what that's what dracula looked
like
in the book he looked kind of like a rat
he was gross
yeah the sexy vampire thing was that was
later later
really you're talking about that i don't
know if you can see it that's what he
looked like which is klaus kenski by the
way that's my that's my favorite poster
that i've ever had klaus kenzie's
vampire that's what they were talking
about in the book
yeah a pitiful [ __ ] yeah it was
gross
yeah
he was a plague that has showed up in
your house and you ain't not your house
but showed up in your in your county
well he was symbolic of a plague right
and i kind of feel like i love that
uh nosferatu
kind of like uh acknowledged that
he was like a human
yes he was like a human symbol of like a
plague yeah was what he was so he looked
like rat like
i think even bram stoker in the novel
it's been a you know probably 20 years
since i've read it
but he does describe him as looking
rat like yeah and we have to remember
that
vampires are the knockoff
the original is like what you saw in
blood vessel
that was what the original was what'd
they call those things stragoi yeah
stragoi
that's a real honky vampire a stragoi
and they were that's a monster it was a
damn monster
it's not like hot no it doesn't look
like hot christopher lee or hot frankly
angela could have sex or hot twilight
it was a thing that was a rat like
undead creature that could have sex
with a dead body and the dead body would
have
yeah to its children
and it could also have sex and it could
have sex with a living person sure and
they would have birth to these things
and there were these different weird
combinations of dead and undead
you know what i mean so it's the stragoi
is what they're talking about
and if you watch a movie blood vessel
which is what not all the maybe four or
five years old not even that old i don't
even think it's three four years it's on
shutter right it's on shutter it's a
that's a good movie that's what that was
really firewood i liked that a lot yeah
that's what i like you had a sim
situation where you had
living vampires and dead and undead
vampires
and that they were having children that
were living children
but it's like vampires zombies yeah
although vampires are kind of zombies
yeah think about it yeah tila says and
the stragoi were wizards
that they were like a witch sure they
could cast a spell i mean of course
that's another angle that you don't that
you don't think taylor says didn't dario
argento make a dracula movie
he did but i prefer to not think about
it yeah because it was really
really not good
i mean
look daario i love dario argento i do
i decorated my whole like old house
i decorated my whole house
on the suspiria aesthetic
i love daria argento
profanda russ i have a poster right
there yeah
but
his dracula was really not good
really not good his phantom of the opera
wasn't wasn't that great either
he he kind of lost it
you know in the old days but you know
honestly he made so many good movies
back in the day he should have just
stopped and just coasted on that [ __ ]
so yeah so christopher lee like i said
even though i kind of feel like a lot of
people
i i feel like christopher lee's dracula
was the perfect
um
middle ground
between the monstrous dracula and the
romantic dracula because he was still
hot and he was still sexy
but he was also monstrous without
looking monstrous you know what i'm
saying so i think that was like a good
middle ground and i think that's why a
lot of people like liking miss dracula
because honestly bella lugosi i love
bella lugosi i do
his dracula is much more romantic
the frank langella one much later also
very romantic
um and then you have like the nosferatu
type thing you know the early the 1920s
one the remake uh the remake with
klaskinsky
are you know very monstrous
but i feel like christopher lee is like
the perfect distillation of those two
things
where
he's still
sexy you could still see yourself like
falling for that
um but also he's still very scary and
he's very menacing to me he's the
scariest
dracula
you know what i'm saying yeah
um
you know
i don't know i don't know why he i i
just find him the scariest dracula
so yeah so
he was uh played dracula 10 times and he
was kind of like got sick of it as you
would playing the same role 10 times
um
[Music]
honestly he was in the first one
and then it took
eight years for the second one to come
out
and
i mean the first one was like a big deal
because like i said hammer
back then this was the late 50s still
it made a huge cultural impact i don't
think anybody realized
how
long lasting that impact would be
um
so
when they asked him later
to
be dracula again eight years later
he read the script and he was like um
no
he was like this is
not not good
um also i think he didn't like
that dracula didn't talk because the
next one was 1965
dracula prince of darkness which is
actually like a pretty decent flick i
think
but he didn't talk in it
um and he's also like well i don't know
not only does he not talk in it but he's
like also this is like not
we're getting like farther away from the
character
from the book we got t
into in the conversation i want to ask
you something from earlier okay tina did
you actually see the mechanic yet i
don't i know you said you were gonna see
it she saw some other uh
stuff that we talked about i didn't know
if you'd actually seen the mechanic
and [ __ ] i didn't you really weren't
quite clear had you seen vamp
because the vamp is another [ __ ] good
movie
and to be honest with you i'm not super
like vampires are not my favorite horror
monster yeah i don't even know what my
favorite horror monster is it's not
vampires though that's for sure i'm kind
of like sick of vampires but
i like the old school vampires if a new
movie comes out or a new book comes out
and it's vampires i'm kind of like meh
if everybody tells me it's awesome i'll
watch it but
i kind of feel like everything with
vampires has been done
although like you said the thing with
the strigoi
i like that yeah because they went way
back to the [ __ ] old school [ __ ] and
i was like okay i'm like yeah i see what
you're doing i used to be like boy
movies yeah really
more old-school vampires right of what
the original
myth was
i kind of feel like once everything has
gone into a point where there's a whole
sub-genre of erotica
about sexy vampires which like i said
i'm looking at you twilight and that
whole
thing that that's bond
not really
cool with you as a monster anymore so
there's that the weird thing about
[ __ ] blood vessel though is the
stragoi's wife
was kind of sexy in a furry kind of way
remember that's true his wife but like i
said i'm always like
weird sexy yeah yeah yeah sure it was it
wasn't normal sex it was like it was
like something out of a damn it's like
ew gross but also yeah it was kind of
like [ __ ] furry porn right because
she was a [ __ ] rat that's a it's like
a rat sex symbol yeah if you're gonna do
vampires do that route you gotta go
there right go that route go back to the
old country right
back in the hockey model because like
look we've seen enough sparkly ass
weirdos like watching girls while they
sleep and that kind of [ __ ] all right it
says i'm gonna see it tom added it to
the list 13 o'clock podcast need to see
vamp 2 should see
10 to midnight with bronson tom i told
you
i've seen it i've seen it before i
haven't seen 10 and midnight i want to
see it what they got for free right now
on youtube is the assassination by
charles bronson i want to see that too
and we'll see 10 to midnight mango says
but we watch those you're like and
you're like vamp
[ __ ] because our girl's in it and
she's looking great in it it's a good
movie it's a good movie
we should do vampires kiss at some point
too because that has nicolas cage in it
i haven't seen it caging the [ __ ] out
and he eats a cockroach
for real yes oh [ __ ]
i'm surprised you have not seen that i
haven't seen it i've had a couple people
bugging me to do it i'm like i've been
wanting to do it for so long because i
love that movie yeah um
yeah nicholas cage like
chews the [ __ ] scenery big time and
it's awesome look at that hundred dollar
super chat like it's up here yeah a
hundred dollars still sitting i can't
believe that that's a good super chat
thank you very much i can't believe that
i mean still yeah i still can't believe
that yeah
uh cheryl mackwood says i do love the
sexy vampire but klaus kinski was
amazing
i kind of do feel like look i like sexy
vampires too i was like really into anne
ray's back in the day i like that vibe
but it's been done so much it's played
out that if somebody wants to go back to
the old school and do them like a
[ __ ] monster ass vampire i'll watch
that but i don't know i'm more into like
i don't even know if i'm like into like
the [ __ ] regular ass monsters do i
really want to see another vampire movie
or another zombie movie or another
werewolf movie
although there's not a lot of werewolf
movies i'll watch a witch movie i'm just
you know i like witches but
mostly if you're gonna do a monster do
you like a not like a
monster that's like not definable i kind
of like that but i don't know
like i said i'll watch anything if it's
good but
if you're already doing another because
i started reading a book recently
without really knowing anything about it
because it was just like a horror novel
i was like oh it's a vampire novel and i
was just kind of like yeah
it's good but
when i
found out that it was a horror that it
was a vampire novel i was just kind of
like
okay
uh fourth round says frank langella also
gave it a good shake he did and i will
defend
the frank langella the john battham bad
ham directed
uh
dracula from 1979 i think it was
um i actually really like that movie
even though
i don't know if i'd call it a horror
movie it's actually mostly a love story
with horror elements
but
honestly i first saw that movie when i
was a kid probably 10 or 11
and that one scene
where
they find
mina not lucy because they switch the
characters around it's a whole thing we
uh reviewed that movie a while back
but they find her in this underground
tunnel and she's turned into a vampire
and she looks really [ __ ] up like her
face is all [ __ ] up she has like
glowing eyes and stuff
that scene
really [ __ ] me up when i was a kid
um so and i still remember it to this
day so they did a good job with that i
gotta say but yeah
uh all right let's see i saw the netflix
dracula didn't love it
it was all right
it was all right
i think i liked the first
it was a series yeah because i think i
remember watching that
oh pokey's on
um
all right so where was i
bookie's like what what are you doing
[Laughter]
all right so so yeah so we were talking
about christopher lee is dracula which
like i said
depending on what iteration of dracula
you're into
christopher lee made a really good
dracula
he was so
big he was so imposing he was so
menacing
but still
super sexy so you could kind of see how
girls would be like all right
you know what i mean
so i kind of feel like he was a good
middle point between those two things
monstrous and sexy at the same time
so there was that but like i said he did
kind of get sick of playing it which
like i said as an actor you probably
would
now uh according to
lee himself
he doesn't feel like his career as such
started
until
1958 when he was
in a tale of two cities
uh as the marquis de sade when he i read
a tale of two cities i don't remember
marquis decided being a character in
that but uh no he wasn't i was gonna say
i was like i'm pretty sure i read that
it happened at the same time sure but he
was i will give you that about steel
yeah i guess during that but i mean it
was a real character that was going on
but i read a tale of two cities yeah
they didn't [ __ ] in high school and i
don't remember it mentioning that but i
mean it's been a long time so i'm
willing to like oh it went down to zero
went to zero went to zero
come on
you can do it
so yeah so he was in this
and this was actually his 43rd movie
honestly reading about
reading christopher lee's and peter
cushing's
career trajectories
it kind of made me feel better a bit
because
they were in a [ __ ] ton of movies
before they really got recognized
and
i don't know that just kind of made me
feel better in a way because sometimes i
kind of feel like well if you haven't
made it by
the time you're in your 20s it's never
going to happen blah blah blah
but
it didn't really happen for either of
them
yeah they were working yeah they were
doing stuff
but they didn't get like legendary
status until later until they were like
older you know what i mean so i kind of
i don't know that that just like kind of
made me happier uh so yeah so
when he'd been in tale of two cities
since 1958 he was already
he had already been 43 movies at this
point
so
for the next few years though uh he kind
of got frustrated because he couldn't
get out of again he got typecast
in the horror genre
and
he wasn't averse to it like i said for a
paycheck but he was kind of like
wishing that he could be in some other
stuff
so at this point 1962
he auditions for a role in the movie the
longest day which is a world war two
yeah
now interestingly even though he
auditioned for the [ __ ] and even though
he'd actually been in the military was
an actual
he had flown planes he hunted nazis
whatever he got turned down because the
quote was audiences won't
accept you as a military type
that's looking funny i love it i love it
he's like um i've actually been in the
military and i've actually like killed
people and nazis and stuff but okay
okay they're full of [ __ ]
well
like i said people that have actually
done [ __ ] and people that have perceived
to have done [ __ ] that's two different
things that's two different caddies
sometimes they overlap a lot of times
not always got bad hair nuts
slightly over here slightly overweight
that's what i'm saying that's why you
can't that's why i always say you can't
judge people by appearance because
[ __ ] you see in the movies that's not
really how [ __ ] goes in real life like
maybe the hero that saved everybody
looks like a dork with like bad clothes
and like you said bag bad hair back
teeth [ __ ] like that uh christopher lee
even though obviously he looked like a
big giant uh badass to us
and had actually been in the military
had actually hunted nazis uh from a
movie point of view he didn't look like
people's perception of what they thought
somebody's military would look like so
he didn't get the [ __ ] part which is
hilarious that's hilarious
uh so yeah 1965 to 1969 those four years
uh he was actually which some people
brought up in the comments earlier he
was in a bunch of uh fu manchu movies uh
playing the villain as i said you know
problematic nowadays because he wasn't
asian by any stretch of the imagination
he was only he was halfway half italian
it's only problematic in your mind
well
they're actors they're just acting
i'm eating some strawberry eating
they're not they're not fake newtons
they're strawberry newtons well they're
not actually strawberry they're like the
off-brand strawberries
from from dollar general stores
to be honest you gave me some of those
last night and they taste kind of weird
to me
no they well they taste okay but they're
good
i don't know they have like a weird like
off taste i'm not like into it
they're it's like eating uh um
i did a couple of things last night
kind of but i don't know there's like a
weird aftertaste that i'm not super into
they're beautiful
[ __ ] he went too i went with him we
went to dollar general yesterday he
spent 60 dollars
on soda yeah and snacks okay fifty
dollars i spent ten dollars i bought a
couple coffee drinks i bought some
granola bars
and
uh some crackers
so i just i i got that
but you got fifty dollars worth of soda
and cookies yeah
those strawberries are not unusual there
i don't know they're weird though i
don't know
you gave me a couple last night i was
like these are good but
i don't know if i'd eat them again
they're a little weird too beautiful
they're a little weird tasting they're
beautiful to me
like i said if i'm gonna
have the calories
i want to have something like delicious
you know what i mean i'm jacked up on
all kinds of stuff i can eat whatever i
want it just turns into muscle
yeah good for you i just [ __ ] does
this synthesize that [ __ ] into [ __ ]
pro into muscle yeah sure
yeah
work out a lot
i'm like five teenagers
you're like five like five teenagers
bundled up into one person yeah
that's why i'm an [ __ ]
oh is that your explanation what was
your explanation before you started
taking testosterone
because you were kind of an [ __ ]
before you didn't say what it is yeah
yeah i'm like it's all kinds of stuff
all happening at once
[Laughter]
at least you have an excuse see this is
how these [ __ ] are they're constantly
trying to undermine you and [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just a man i'm looking for a
[ __ ] weakness
there's no weakness
oh okay that's what you say
that's what you say
do you want to know drake uh yeah why
not put it right there all right put it
right there and then it'll
it'll be sucked up
yeah
so yeah so he played food manchu like i
said he played some other quote-unquote
ethnic roles uh
later
but yeah he did play foo manchu several
times
the only one of those i've seen
what was the one that was on mst
the castle of fu manchu
i have to say
look i love christopher lee i do
that movie
was
incomprehensible
i have watched
every single episode of mystery science
theater i've watched every terrible
movie that they and several rifftrax
ones as well so i've watched like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
bad movies in my life
castle of fu manchu for some reason
i don't usually revisit that episode
even though christopher lee is in it
because
something about that movie
i can't like what the [ __ ] is going i
can't like get a handle on it
and i can't even get enough of a handle
on it to like enjoy
somebody making fun of it because
it's so incomprehensible that i just
can't
i don't know there's like nothing for me
to like latch onto i guess
but that's the only one that i've seen
that he's done
yeah and like i said that's no
[ __ ] man that's no [ __ ] uh you know
knock on christopher lee everybody's got
to eat
but
and maybe it was better in the uncut
version
that i presumably didn't see
that wasn't on mystery science theater
but
that movie
i don't know that one just pisses me off
for some reason and not like i said i'll
watch ed wood movies
like voluntarily
that one castle of manchu
i don't know i can't watch that episode
it just it makes me angry because i have
no [ __ ] one seed to the other i have
no idea what's going on
so and that just like makes me mad so
yeah so he played like fu manchu
uh over four years he played himself
like several times
so um now
this is like funny to me
so 1970
uh he gets a he gets a role
and he's narrating a movie about the
marquis de sade which you would think
would be kind of like oh everything's on
the up and up what happened with that
though
was that
he narrated the [ __ ] and then behind his
back or
whatever
the movie was straight up like softcore
porn and christopher lee didn't know
that until after
and so he was a little upset about it
because he's like i didn't really know
that i was lending my talents to a
sophomore porn movie and he was like
kind of upset about it because he wasn't
there for all the stuff that was filmed
he's like so they filmed all these like
people having sex and all of a sudden i
didn't know about it so he was kind of
upset about it but you know
what are you gonna do
um
at this point uh he stars in the 1970s
as sherlock holmes smarter older brother
mycroft
uh in the movie the private life of
sherlock holmes
and that was kind of like
he
uh at least from his perception that was
the role that sort of catapulted him
into
being something other than
quote unquote the horror guy
and then three years after that 1974
most of you here will know
he was in
the wicker man
as lord summer isle
he was so
well it was his favorite role yeah i
think even even until his death it was
the original one the original he was so
into this movie that he said i will be
in this movie for free
he did not take any payment for this
movie he was in it for free
uh because he was
that into this movie as far as i know
yeah i love the [ __ ] wicker man it's
so good and that was actually his
favorite
role as lord samurai in the wicker man
uh it was based on a book called ritual
and he was so into it like i said that
he was just kind of like look i'll be in
it for free you guys just make it and
apparently i didn't get paid for it
uh he was also in the three musketeers
and the four musketeers in the 1970s
and uh as i mentioned because his
step cousin ian fleming
um
[Music]
was into was offered actually offered
him the role
of uh dr no
the villain
and
christopher lee was like okay absolutely
but then the studio was like hey we
didn't like give you permission to do
that even though you're the ian fleming
said that i want you to play like doctor
now okay um
but the studio is like yeah we didn't
give you permission to do that actually
even though you're the person that wrote
the actual book so you know why should
we listen to you but yeah so there was
that
so he didn't actually get to but
he did get to play a bond villain at
some point uh in the man with a golden
gun he played francisco scaramonga
uh in the mail with the golden gun so
you know what i mean that's good so he
did get to be a bond villain
now uh at this point
so it's 1977 and he's like well
uh you know everybody kind of knows like
yeah i'm kind of known as a horror actor
but i've done some other stuff
and he felt like he'd done kind of
everything that he could do in the uk
so he felt like he should move to the
u.s at this point so he did actually
move to the us in 1977
and his first american role
was actually in the disaster film
airport 77.
remember that one like all the 70s like
we went out like an american like a
disaster movie
[ __ ] [ __ ] like a few
years back we didn't watch airport 77
though did we i forgot christopher lee
was in that that was like an ensemble
cast though
um
interestingly lee was offered
what are you doing
she pulled books out
lee was actually offered the
what is now known as the leslie nielsen
role in
airplane the comedy
and he turned it down
and later on he would say that that was
a big mistake he totally should have
done that
but
leslie nielsen got it and obviously
leslie nielsen went on to like a whole
other like comedic career because of
that
but
that's kind of cool though because
christopher lee was like
i'm willing to
laugh at myself i'm willing to like
spoof
you know this these genres this type of
character
and
i don't know he turned it down and he
kind of felt bad about it he said that
was a mistake that he should have taken
the role in airplane the leslie nielsen
role is what i'm talking about
uh i don't know man leslie nelson in
that role is i mean
because at that point it's hard for
people nowadays to understand like
leslie nielsen it's even hard for me
because i grew up in the 70s like but if
you'd grown up earlier than that leslie
nielsen was all also known always known
for like serious roles yeah him doing
like comedic stuff
was
different
in the late 70s that was like
kind of weird to see and it's so funny
because i think people of our generation
and younger
only know leslie nielsen as like a funny
like a comedic actor but he actually
started out as a serious actor
so
tina's here talking about mid-summer
yeah mid-summer was [ __ ] awesome god
i love mid-summer yeah i mean i love ari
asters all of his [ __ ] i love i love
hereditary yeah i love mid-summer
they're two completely different films
but
that's kind of what it's the same
director but cute little chick with that
little round head [ __ ]
getting all into that damn cult and
killing that [ __ ] florence pew what's
what's her name florence piano florence
but yeah
damn that was a weird ass [ __ ] movie
man can i say is it bad that like when
she killed her boyfriend at the end i'm
like man
all right he was kind of
he was kind of a douche t you got to
feel that bad you got to see fight with
my family that same girl starred in that
as she played paige the wrestler
and it takes place in here in florida
she moves here from england to go to
florida moved to florida the rock and
[ __ ] the rock [ __ ] she's as cute
as [ __ ] i like it yeah it's a great
movie and and [ __ ] it was funny man me
and jenny were watching fighting with my
family in the theater
here in florida looking to go oh it's
just right on the street oh my god i
don't know where this is i know where
the exit that is
yeah that's so crazy fighting my family
is a very kind of
very florida and very england movie it's
where
which i kind of got into because like i
said for a long time i was married to a
british person and i went back and forth
between the two places yeah it was kind
of like yeah
and it is it's an accurate portrayal of
the scene around here
uh mainstream especially if you were
training to be a [ __ ]
wrestler and the [ __ ]
dwayne johnson is [ __ ]
talking to you it's good movie great
movie we'll have it on blu-ray i love i
love [ __ ] fighting with my family i
do like that movie it's very it's very
fun it's very heartwarming i like it
every minute based on a true story i
like it every bit as much as uh
mid-summer fighting with my family but
they're all fighting with my people well
when i saw it what did i note i'm saying
i'm talking about this fight it
with my family
and um i like it every bit yeah it's
about it's a true story it's based on a
real story of paige wrestler paige yeah
she's a british wrestler she's kind of
like a gothy chick yeah
and she like comes yeah she leaves
england in the www what the [ __ ] what
wwwe
or whatever it is and i don't know
anything yeah dwayne johnson is there
and he's meeting yeah the rock is in it
and they're playing himself the rock is
in it playing himself and [ __ ]
they're up here in orlando just a couple
[ __ ] miles up a road [ __ ] trainer
to become a wrestler and i do love the
family but it's a great movie we've seen
it like three times at this point i got
it on blu-ray we saw the theater yeah
once or twice we have it we bought it
it's like it's super it's a it's a
feel-good movie
very much yeah
yeah and you don't have to give a [ __ ]
about wrestling watch it no because it's
fun
it's just like a nice character study
because i don't give a [ __ ] about it
yeah
but you know i don't even know i didn't
even know who she was yeah so uh so yeah
so like i said christopher lee offered
the leslie nielsen role in an airplane
but did not take it and regretted it for
the rest of his life is gonna watch it
okay yeah you'll like that it's good
it's good i like it it's it's super fun
uh so yeah he was also on uh saturday
night live at this point
um
and
at this point like he he said that it
was like really terrifying i guess it
would be because it's like live but
among the many people who watched him on
the saturday live thing was steven
spielberg steven spielberg was so
impressed by his uh
performance on there that he actually
asked him to be in his movie
1941 which if you know anything about
steven spielberg
was one of his rare flops
but i haven't seen a long time so i
can't really say i don't know if it's
like a [ __ ] movie or not but
i remember it being like one of his very
uh rare not so good movies but he chris
really was in that as well
um so at this point
so throughout like 80s and 90s because
like i said chris burley is getting
older at this point but he was in a
whole bunch of different movies uh at
this point he's doing musicals even
comedies he was in dramas
um and he was in he was on like a lot of
tv [ __ ] like in the us and in britain as
well
now as i mentioned earlier when we were
talking about
white actors playing
quote unquote ethnic roles
1998
christopher lee gets cast
as muhammad ali
jinnah who is the founder of pakistan i
believe i brought that up earlier
the movie was called jenna
and
uh i kind of feel like
i don't know i kind of feel like most
people because they did shoot it in
pakistan so they did have a lot of like
locals that were kind of like watching
the [ __ ] like is this dude gonna pull
this off or what
but it does seem like most of the locals
that were watching were like okay fair
enough that's kind of like i haven't
seen it
but i don't really see that many like
bad reviews of it
um
it wasn't like a big commercial success
but obviously a movie about the founder
of pakistan isn't going to be
but uh you know from what i could
determine from critical uh you know
consensus was that it actually he
actually did a good job of it
so at this point um
you know obviously christopher lee big
fan of jarror tolkien uh you know lord
of the rings all that
he read them uh once a year or so he
said and he had actually met
tolkien
personally
and he had wanted to play gandalf
for a really really long time
now at the point that peter jackson was
making the lord of the rings movies
um
they kind of felt like maybe he wasn't
exactly right or he was maybe slightly
too old to play gandalf
so they offered him the role of saruman
and he was like yes absolutely so he
[ __ ] took it
and this
him being in that like yes him being in
star wars but he was in like the
prequels as count dooku obviously
but i think him being
in the lord of the rings movies i think
that was kind of like what cemented him
uh to other p you know to the next
generation of like moviegoers i guess
so basically this is like funny okay so
this
i love this story from the lord of the
rings set apparently
so
saruman
uh he's supposed to get stabbed in the
back
right
and peter jackson
he says to christopher lee will like
you know scream like you're dying or
whatever
christopher lee apparently allegedly
turns to peter jackson and says
have you ever actually seen a man get
stabbed in the back peter jackson says
uh no can't say that i have
christopher lee says
i have
i know what to do
at this point
so he's like so he did the thing he was
like look i've seen a dude get stabbed
in the back
um you get stabbed in the back it goes
into one of your lungs you can't really
scream and it's just gonna be like this
groaning type situation so that's what
he did he wanted to be like more
realistic but that's like a a story that
goes uh
around about him
so uh because he was such a big hit in
the lord of the rings he got cast in the
updated star wars as count dooku in the
prequels and all that stuff
so there was that he was also in a bunch
of tim burton movies in the 2000s he was
in sleepy hollow all that kind of stuff
because like i said tim burton obviously
big fan of like you know classic horror
he put vincent price in a lot of his
movies as well
and he also put christopher lee in a
bunch of his movies too
now as i mentioned earlier look at pokey
yeah
uh
as i mentioned earlier i was listening
to a couple of metal albums that
christopher lee had made
um
he
recorded a bunch of like opera and metal
stuff between 86 and 1998
so he did a couple of like symphonic
metal albums one of them was called
charlemagne by the sword and the cross
that was 2010
and he did another one that was a couple
years later that was like a sequel to
that and like i said it was like um
it's metal but it's like operatic metal
and it's like a story so they're like
telling a story
with the with a couple of singing voices
so it's on youtube if you want to listen
to it you can because i listened to it
earlier
uh the follow-up was called charlemagne
the omens of death
and that came out in 2013 which was
christopher lee's 91st birthday
i believe he is in
the
guinness book of world records as like
the oldest person to like
do a metal album yeah so you know
um well one guy said that i could be in
[ __ ] wrestling but uh not yet a
couple more a couple more months
probably but then t jumps in and says
the rock loves the star in florida
movies there may be a florida rock
connection i think he's lived here
hadn't he
oh i don't know well he had to because
he was with the wwe and he was training
them here
so yeah they do like they
they do train them here so yeah so yeah
it made sense for the rock to be in that
movie but that uh but that is a great
movie fighting with my family and uh
kind of came and went people didn't
watch it but it's fun moving i mean the
thing about a movie like that is that
it's not like a big tentpole movie yeah
and it's not necessary it kind of falls
in a weird gray area where it's like
you want to call it a sports movie
because it's kind of based around
wrestling but
it's not what it was it's not though i
mean because like i said i don't give a
[ __ ] about wrestling but it was just
like a good
it was kind of a character study it was
good yeah
about a girl who really kind of came
from nowhere and her family it was a
little bit of a fish out of water kind
of story yeah and it was like based on
aurelia yeah and then she comes to
florida to become a wrestler and the
other wrestlers were very different
those girls were more like cheerleaders
stripper
model types that were becoming strippers
and she was kind of like not dumpy but
she was kind of like a more she was
actually a wrestler she was a real she
her family wrestled yeah she had
actually grown up as a wrestler she was
built she was very short she was built
more like a wrestler not like a
cheerleader or a model or whatever and
she was hot i mean she looked kind of
gothy though yeah and so she wasn't like
the bleach blondes no kind yeah no she
was kind of long black hair
[ __ ] kind of muscular physique um she
still she looked great she was a cute
girl but she did not look like a
california style
porn star really is is how a lot of the
[ __ ] female wrestlers looked
um but she's just from england from and
her and her dad ran a [ __ ] basically
like a ghetto [ __ ] wrestling
federation that's because her brother
was her brother was a wrestler as well
and uh she met the rock and uh became a
[ __ ] wrestler and went on tour and
it's just her story of her life
at least or the story of her career not
her whole life but of her career it's a
fun movie
kind of a feel-good movie a movie of
triumph
and uh i don't want to sound cheesy but
like female empowerment you know what i
mean but that's not cheesy well i don't
want to it's
a lot of times they talk about female 5
some cheesy [ __ ] it's really just
human empowerment
it's not uh she's a chick and she
[ __ ] did this [ __ ] and it was cool
and you're like yeah all right and it's
the same girl that played the girl from
[ __ ] mid-summer
yeah florence peter yeah she's been in
his time to show and and i love
hershey's yeah and she's a lot and when
you look at her like yeah she could play
paige yeah
i mean i really liked i really like her
in general and she was like really great
yeah
but yeah so
so not only like christopher lee
was a nazi hunter
he was also
a [ __ ]
like uh you know he was dracula
and he also like spoke a zillion
languages and he also
did all these movies
and
he
sang on sev on heavy metal albums so
i don't know like what other boxes you
could check
to be cooler than that i'm not really
sure
if you could
but
you know if you want to try good luck
but i honestly i think we can close it
up christopher lee is pretty much the
coolest person that's ever lived
i think we can
just close it up and like stop but yeah
so honestly and honestly he
even though he didn't really think of
himself as an actor until he was in his
mid-20s
he hadn't really thought about it
um
by the end of his life he was kind of
like i
uh you know acting for him
was not even like a job anymore it was
just like his life
so he just kept doing it until
he died
i mean he
lived into his 90s
and he worked
pretty much until he died
um he was just [ __ ] on it and he's
like i can't even imagine like what else
i would be doing this is my life
um you know it's not just a job for me
this is my life
so it's interesting how
something that he didn't really think
about when he was younger became like
his life later on
uh 2011
he actually
was in his first hammer film
in 35 years he was in a film called
because hammer came back in case you
guys didn't know
uh they did the woman in black and all
that kind of stuff he was in a movie
called the resident with hillary swank
uh in 2011
and he got a back injury in that though
uh because he was older at that stage
and they wanted him to actually be in
the sequel to the wicker man the wicker
tree but um he was like well because of
the back injury he couldn't uh fully
commit to it
so they did give him a small role in it
uh though where he didn't have to like
move around
now uh
at this point though he was kind of
having some uh respiratory problems and
some heart problems
so he couldn't really
uh take on as many roles as he used to
even though as i mentioned
he kind of thought you know this is my
life now it's like not even work to me
but he still kept doing like voice over
stuff he kept doing narrations anything
that he could do i mean he did that
pretty much up until he [ __ ] died
which is amazing
his final film
was an independent film called angels of
nodding hill
he died
uh june
2015. he was 93
years old of heart failure
um he was in as i mentioned earlier 208
films
which i don't know if this is still the
case
but
at the time that he died
more than anyone else in history
2008 movies
so
there's that
so let's talk about peter cushing now
because i kind of feel like we haven't
even gotten peter cushing yet
damn are we halfway through it
yeah we're more than waiting for it
well we talked about christopher lee now
we got to talk about peter cushing how
long have you been running
two hours and fifty one minutes okay
well you know
that's how it goes i guess
that was one show right there all right
well these two guys like i said a lot of
the shit's gonna overlap all right but i
do want to talk about peter cushing
though okay
um cause peter cushing
he's kind of like
i don't know i kind of feel like these
two guys it's like they're
they always get paired up they're very
different but they're you know the the
friendship is kind of like uh you know
very iconic it's like salt and pepper
yeah kind of
because peter cushing like like i said
christopher lee was just kind of like
acting
was almost kind of like i don't want to
say it was like an afterthought but it
was like something that he wasn't really
into
and then his mid-20s like oh yeah acting
okay and then he like proceeded to like
kick everyone's ass at it
um whereas peter cushing
was kind of like he knew he wanted to be
an actor from like when he was a child
and that was all he ever wanted to do
you know what i mean so there was that
so peter cushing born in surrey 1913
uh so he was the younger of two boys
uh he had a brother named george who was
three years older
sadly his mom that and i kind of feel
like this happened a lot back in this
back in the old days
his mom
she'd already had a boy
so she wanted a girl
so when peter was born she's like well
let's just pretend he's a girl
she would let his hair grow out she
would dress him in like female clothes
like put pink ribbons in his hair [ __ ]
like that
i kind of feel like that was kind of
common
at least with like famous people that
i've talked about from this time period
which is messed up
let your kid just be their kid holy crap
but yeah i wish you were a girl i'm
gonna like dress it like how [ __ ] up
is that stop it that's a person knock it
out
but yeah
she wished he was a girl so dress him as
a girl
he doesn't seem to have had any lasting
impact from it but please don't do that
uh his dad
um who was kind of from an upper-class
family
uh very reserved very
you know not really present for the
family
uh peter later said yeah i didn't really
get to know him very well so he was very
distant
uh his mom was actually the daughter of
a carpet
merchant
and was considered lower class than her
husband so that whole that class
conflict was kind of like a big deal
when he was growing up
uh have to say though that among uh
peter's extended family
there were a lot of stage actors his
paternal grandfather was a stage actor
as was his
aunt and his step-uncle
so there was some history in the family
of
theatrical
uh kind of [ __ ]
so during the first world war uh they
lived in dulwich they moved to pearly
after the war ended 1918.
he was raised during the first world war
but uh he later recalled that his mom
was very adept at
pretending that the war wasn't going on
whenever there were air raids or
something like that she would like
just hide under the table like pretend
it's a game you know what i mean you're
a little kid you don't know any better
so he didn't really like
experience all of the uh hardships of
the first world war because he was a
little kid and his mom kind of like
shielded him from it
um peter cushing also very uh sickly
child he had pneumonia in his infancy
a couple of times
and also got a double pneumonia which i
guess is called something else nowadays
but yeah he was real sick when he was
growing up
um and honestly double pneumonia was
something that killed a lot of people
back in those days
but he did survive
um now during this time period when he
was a little kid he actually ended up
seeing a stage production of peter pan
and at this point he was kind of like
i want to do that like so he was very
aware from an early age that he wanted
to be an actor so when he was a little
kid he was very into like dressing up in
costumes and like make-believe and doing
puppet shows and [ __ ] like that so he
knew he wanted to be an actor from when
he was very very young
so he goes from a school in uh south
london then he goes to a place called
shorum grammar school in shorm by the
sea
um which i think was a boarding school
but at this point he was kind of like
homesick
so he didn't really like the boarding
school situation
he was only there for one term and then
he just went back home
then he went to the grammar school
at that point
and then he did some kind of like
physical stuff he did swimming he did
like cricket rugby stuff like that but
all the other sports he wasn't super
into uh and also much like christopher
lee in math uh he was kind of a poor
student
uh a little bit add gotta say not really
into
i don't know he kind of peter cushing to
me
seemed like somebody as a kid
uh seemed like somebody that was very
in his own head
in the sense that
i want to do what i want to do
and whatever you guys are
trying to do or trying to teach me i'm
not interested in it i just want to do
what i want to do he kind of seemed like
that kind of dude that's kind of what i
feel from his from his thing
uh because like i said if he wasn't into
it he just was not paying attention so
he was like not really that good a
student
so he didn't get that uh great at grades
but his older brother
uh
who was a good student would do some of
his stuff for him so you know there was
that
interestingly um
yeah like i said he was real into like
acting painting anything like artistic
he was into it but other than that he
didn't care
one of the things that he was really
into weirdly even though he was very
very british
his favorite thing when he was a kid he
was really into
tom mix which if you don't know who that
is
um he was a
uh very famous back in the old old days
as like a cowboy
uh you know kind of movie star not even
movie star was it movies or radio or
something it was a long time ago
tom mix was
kind of the [ __ ] back in the old days as
a cowboy
and
uh peter cushing was super super into
that
he was really into like westerns and
cowboy [ __ ]
that's what he wanted to do
now when he was little he had a teacher
at school
that
saw that he was kind of like yeah this
dude might you know grow up to be an
actor so he's like why don't you do some
theater stuff so he would you know paint
sets and [ __ ] like that
and then later on uh
most of the
plays that they would do when he was a
teenager he would get to be the lead
now
when peter christian got older he wanted
to be an actor but
his dad of course was like no i don't
really want you to do that
um even though he had several family
members that were in the theater
um so what he did though as a compromise
he said well
because peter's so into like drawing and
art and that kind of stuff he's like
well i'm gonna get you a job
as a like a surveyor like or for a
surveyor kind of thing or architecture
type [ __ ] so he got him a job as a
surveyor's assistant
now
peter did this job for three years but
he [ __ ] hated it because all he did
the whole time
was
imagine all of the other stuff like he
would draw
all of these like
structures and stuff
and he'd be like yeah we should build
this and that and the other thing and
then like people would look at it and be
like yeah we can't build that he's like
man [ __ ] that i don't give a [ __ ] about
what he's just like look at that though
so he was more interested in like
[ __ ]
the idealized
you know what i mean like the cool like
buildings he's like well you can't build
it we'll figure it out one of these days
but he was very into like more of like
the imagining stage rather than like the
actual having to build stage so there
was that
so uh at this point um
so he starts he was in like a lot of
school plays and [ __ ] like that
uh he was on a lot of amateur plays that
were going around the town that were not
affiliated with school
um and one thing is he would apply for a
lot of
other auditions and a lot of other roles
but he got turned down a lot because he
didn't have any professional experience
so at this point he applies for a
scholarship
at the guildhall school of music and
drama this was in london
now he auditioned
um and his audition took place before
uh an actor named alan ainsworth
and this actor
hated him so much that he said
you
don't come back
until you
improve your
diction
he said i don't really like the way you
talk
you're never gonna get anywhere like
talking like that whatever so he sent
him away
peter cushing
uh was
stubborn so he
wrote
more than uh almost two dozen letters
to get a scholarship
to this [ __ ] school
which actually worked because
the guy that managed the theater whose
name was bill frazier
he finally said okay come in here
i will meet you just to get you to
[ __ ] stop writing me letters because
you keep writing the letters trying to
get a scholarship
so he came in there
uh so
while the meeting was going on he's like
okay fine you can have one
walk-on roll
as like a [ __ ] it's just a throwaway
role they gave him like on some play
they were doing that night
and that was his professional stage
debut it was a
a play called cornelius by jb priestly
and that was the first time he'd ever
been on stage he didn't have any lines
and he just basically had to come on
stage and like do some [ __ ] he was a
courier and that's it
but because of that he got a scholarship
and they gave him again like christopher
lee they can like odd jobs around
theater like clean up [ __ ] yeah sell
some you know
soda to people [ __ ] like that assistant
stage manager
you gotta work your way up
so at this point it's 1936
and peter cushing gets a job with the
repertory uh theater company called
southampton rep what have you got oh
nice
uh and he gets a bunch of like bit rolls
[ __ ] like that
and over the next three years uh he got
an apprenticeship at southampton rep and
auditioned for character roles
uh in in a bunch of other theaters over
this time
he got about 100 different roles
although like i said most of them were
background [ __ ] like that
at this point uh when he was in
southampton
he meets a woman named dorian lawrence
who was 18 at the time
and they got engaged to be married
i love this
they got engaged
and wikipedia says lawrence who is his
fiancee
broke off the engagement
citing
peter's frequent crying
and bringing his parents on dates
okay so there's that
peter cushing i mean
i love him so much
he does really seem to me to be like the
ultimate
when he was a kid he was just like like
oh i'm so into like acting he was like
that kind of dude
and then he was like very very sensitive
you know
he's very sensitive he's a bird watcher
he's a vegetarian
and so that's what i said that's why
it's like it's so funny that like him
and like christopher lee are kind of
like
that different but they still were like
friends but i don't know i can see it
so at this point
um he decides well i'm gonna be in
movies
and as i said he was really into tom mix
like the american cowboy star
so he decides i have to go to hollywood
so
before he he wasn't famous in the uk at
all like he just been like some
background [ __ ] in like [ __ ] stage
productions in the uk
but he decides he's going to move to us
1939
his dad
bought him a one-way ticket to hollywood
so he moved there he had 50 pounds
and that's it
and so uh while he was there
he ended up meeting this dude named
larry goodkind who worked for columbia
pictures
and
he's like okay well there's this other
dude i know that works for edward small
productions
go there and see what's going on
so he went there
and they were starting to film
uh
the man in the iron mask which was
directed by james whale who if you guys
don't know also directed frankenstein
bride of frankenstein
um
so yes so they were working on that
and peter cushing got hired
as a stand-in
for
the main dude
louis hayward now what they did
they were doing like a split screen
because louis hayward was playing two
roles
so what they would do was they would
have the main actor here and they would
have peter cushing here
like you know doing the scene with him
and then later
they would cut peter cushing out
and put the other performance of louis
hayward in the other side you know what
i mean so peter cushing was in the movie
technically
but
his contributions were not on screen
because he was just
you know the guy the main actor
yeah the main actor was working against
now peter cushing later said well it's
probably good that my [ __ ] wasn't on
screen because it wasn't that good but
he did learn a lot from the process but
so that was technically his first movie
even though he wasn't really in it
because all his [ __ ] was like cut out
um
so yeah
they they actually let him be in it
because they said can you fence and he
was like oh totally even though he
couldn't but you know what i mean
um so a couple days after that peter
cushing happened to be in schwab's drug
store which if you know anything about
hollywood history was kind of like the
place that you would hang out
to get like quote unquote discovered
so he was and that's where you got like
all the scuttlebutt like on the good
[ __ ] rolls and stuff
so he's in there
and he hears that hal roach the producer
is looking for an english guy
he's like i'm looking for somebody
that'll be in a laurel and hardy movie
so he hears about that and he goes and
auditions and he gets it
so he's actually in a laurel and hardy
movie a chump at oxford which came out
in 1940
yeah
um
he said look i was only in it for a
little bit he's like it took me like a
week to shoot it it was like a couple of
minutes
um but he says
he was proud to work with uh what he
called the two of the greatest comedians
the cinema has ever produced and like
you said it uh taught him a lot about
the movie-making business
yeah
what is she she's like oh god oh god
stop it daddy
she's gonna be like what look at her
face
look at her face
she's like what are you doing
what are you doing
[Laughter]
she's like what she doesn't understand
it
she keeps like looking at you like
what are you doing what are you doing
good job she's like stop yeah yeah
you're drunk daddy yeah she's playing
though she knows
she's having fun
you're super drunk
no not super drunk just a little bit
bless you sweetie
this is [ __ ]
oh what are you sneezing for she's been
sneezing like all like not all day but
she's been she sneezes
hopefully she's not oh she's not sick
but yeah so he was in that
and then he was also uh the second lead
male role in a
movie called vigil in the night from
1940
and this was kind of the first movie
that kind of drew him any like attention
of any uh you know degree in hollywood
so he was in a couple of other hollywood
movies uh there was a war movie called
they dare not love from 1941 uh which he
was in uncredited
um
which james whale had also directed
he was also in a bunch of uh mgm did a
bunch of short films called the passing
parade
uh in also in 1941 and he was in one of
those
now
it seemed like the one of those that he
was in
uh a lot of kind of like hollywood
insiders or whatever like saw him in
that it's like oh that dude's gonna be a
star you know what i mean
and so they were kind of like all up in
it but at this point peter cushing was
like man i don't really like like it
here i was i would rather be back in
england he was getting homesick
so he decided that he was gonna go back
home at some point
so at this point he goes uh he moves
back to new york city like because he's
like well i'm gonna go back to england
at some point new york city's closer
obviously so he goes back to new york
and at that point he got some radio
commercials he like joined a summer
stock theater company because he was
trying to like raise enough money to
like
you know fly back to england
uh so while he was in new york he
actually got noticed by a broadway
theater talent scout so 1941 he actually
made his broadway debut
uh in a drama called the seventh trumpet
however uh the play didn't really get
that good reviews and ran for only 11
days and then it closed
so at that point peter cushing went back
to england and this was during the
second world war
now at this point uh peter cushing
wanted to do his part although he had a
lot of health problems that prevented
him from joining active duty
however he did um sign on to entertain
the troops so he was part of the
entertainment national service
association the e-n-s-a
which
was the thing that would go around like
entertaining all the troops during the
war so he would go around and like do
plays and [ __ ] like that he was with
them for like uh quite a while
now during the time he actually uh got
on to that because he was in a noble
coward play called private lives uh the
guy that was the main
uh role in that got actually conscripted
to go to the front lines so he took that
dude's place so he was in that role for
a while
now while he was in there
uh he met
his
wife
helen beck
and as i said they married in 1943
and would remain married for a very long
time and after she died as some people
have mentioned
uh he was pretty much like killing time
until he died as well that's really sad
it it well
i mean he was like i'm checking out he
loved her yeah he still kept working
yeah um but he never
was he said and he said to an
interviewer he's like just the heart
went out of everything like after she
was gone
so he didn't really like he still worked
and [ __ ] like that but
he was just like waiting to join her
which
yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up but
i mean it's kind of understandable they
had been married a long time they got
married in like the 40s
and you know they were married until she
died
and she died like
uh several decades before he did like a
couple decades before he did so
he just wasn't the same after she was
gone but yeah um he did meet her
right around this time uh she was also
an actor
and uh helen beck uh in
1942 19. so they married in 1943
and at this point um he actually ended
up having to leave this uh leave the
uh what he called the ns the ensa
because he had like health problems like
i said he had a lot of health problems
throughout his life he had lung
congestion
uh so
he had to like not do it anymore
so at this point uh he's kind of
broke-ass
and he had to
you know they have uh for actors he was
in like actors unions actors guild stuff
like that so he had to like kind of
collect money from
them as well actors benevolent fund
things like that because he was trying
to find work and couldn't really find
all that many he did um actually find
some parts and plays but a lot of the
parts that he found
um the plays didn't really either make
it past rehearsals or they'd only do
like a couple
uh you know
showings and then they would close so
there was that
now he was in a production in 1945
of a play called the rivals
uh and that kind of gave him enough
money to pay off some debts
but during the war it was really [ __ ]
rough to like make it as an actor
so at some point he had to like do some
other work so he
designed some uh women's scarves
for like department stores and stuff
to make money
so there was that so he was doing some
other [ __ ]
now after the war ended in autumn of
1946
um he actually
tried to get
a part in a play called porn yesterday
uh he didn't get it
but
this play was being put on by
lawrence olivier who was directing at
the time
so he went to audition
and
they asked him if he could do an
american accent
and he was like i don't think i can and
he tried to do it and he couldn't do it
uh so he's so laurence olivier says uh i
appreciate you not wasting my time i'll
remember you
which sounds like [ __ ] but it was
actually not [ __ ] because even
though he didn't get that part because
he couldn't do an american accent
lawrence olivier did actually remember
him
and cast him
later on in 1947 in hamlet like i said
first film that him and christopher lee
were in together small parts
but the fact that lawrence olivier did
remember him and called him back after
all that time
um but like i said peter cushing at this
point was in his 40s
and thought that well the career i've
chosen is a failure [ __ ] a little bit
not even knowing
that well see that just goes to show
even if you're old
sometimes it takes that long it does
well and especially in entertainment
kind of [ __ ] because you don't really
know yeah
entertainment kind of well especially
like acting you know music [ __ ] like
that
generally
it's better to be younger most people
are very successful when they're younger
but not always no there's not always
there are certain people that can arrive
on the scene because of their gravitas
and their looks as an old person
and kind of like their leadership skills
the younger [ __ ] crews and hollywood
want them around they like them
so then all of a sudden they start
giving them these bad ass roles and they
get better and better and better but
they're always that like the heavies or
they're the
the bigger players in the [ __ ]
in the storyline they're not the love
interest or the the hero per se
there's just somebody else who's kind of
in there driving the story along
example like darth vader okay in star
wars
he he's not the love interest but he's
driving that [ __ ] story along
and you need an older person for that
well you just have to
i mean particularly as it in regards to
acting
you just have to understand that not
everybody can be
like star material that's a very
narrow
uh physical thing and that's a very
narrow but honestly if you're a
character actor yeah in a lot of ways
that might be better because because
they need you because they need you you
can find a niche that you're good at so
you can like constantly work
and i kind of feel like
if you're like a really good character
particularly if you're in horror movies
like i said we're
talking about right now
people are going to remember you [ __ ]
decades from now whereas a star
maybe not because there's a lot of those
it's very bland then there's just the
other factor that where the crew is
people in their 30s maybe 40s
and you might have an actor who's
[ __ ] in his 50s who has a lot of
gravitas
who's actually kind of adding
importance and gravidas to the
production
oh we got him so this is going to be
awesome
so
the younger crew is now all of a sudden
kind of like
looking up to this older dude and
like this is going to be a great project
because you're on it you know so
it's it's chemistry
you know it is and not everybody and
like i said not everybody is destined to
be
a star
but in the long term
i don't know if it's better to be a star
because how many stars
do we remember
from back in the old days because
sometimes like i do research about like
movies from the 20s or 30s and there
were people that were stars back then
nobody knows their name nowadays
character actors though
people remember them those people
but you know horror actors [ __ ] like
that people still remember that
but if you were just like a leading man
there's a word for it but i forgot what
it was they're all stars you're talking
about like leading man and leading
ladies yeah i'm talking about yeah they
kind of are they're interchangeable
because it's a very well it's a very and
i mean
by definition if you are a leading man
or a leading
it's kind of like you're trying to
capture the zeitgeist of whatever the
culture is at the time yeah which is
fleeting 20s right yeah so it's like
whatever was hot or popular or whatever
you're trying to like stand in for like
the hot every person of that year
and that doesn't always carry over the
supporting actors and the supporting
characters that you remember right not
so much i mean how many people like okay
nowadays 2022
how many people like who do we remember
from the silent era for example we
remember people that were character
actors we remember people that were in
horror movies we remember you know
people like that you don't really
remember
i mean you do but to a lesser extent so
i do kind of feel like you had to have
something if you were just in a movie
like as the leading man or the leading
lady
a lot of times those people are not
remembered as well
as people who played villains or people
who played
more character type of roles like i said
that doesn't
you know track entirely across the thing
but i do kind of feel like it's more
because you have to have something
different
if people
remember you if you're just like a
generic
yeah you're just like a generic
good-looking person from back then
i kind of feel like particularly like
the male actors back then that were
leading men
i mean they were very interchangeable
because they were just like you know
they're all like good-looking men
of the time and they were just supposed
to be the hero and
it just you know but a lot of them we
don't remember them nowadays we remember
people like boris karloff we remember
people like bella lugosi you remember
people that
were
different in some way they either played
villains or if they played leads they
were they had something different about
them so
i do kind of feel
like maybe why
i don't know i i know if you're in the
moment
uh i understand if you're a working
actor
yes you want to be a quote unquote star
because you'll make a lot of money
you know i get that everybody's gotta
eat everybody's gonna have a job
but
in the long term i do kind of feel like
it's probably better to be to find your
niche as a character actor and just like
[ __ ]
go down that [ __ ] look at the movie
the black cat
the lady man the leading lady you
they're in that movie i don't even
remember their name
everybody remembers bella lugosi and
boris
with that [ __ ] everybody
nobody remembers there well
some people remember but most people
don't remember and they were in the
leading man the leading lady were good
in the movie it's just that
they're generic they're generic there's
a lot of those they're generic
characters there's a lot of generic
good-looking people right yeah
cycling through hollywood
that were stars at whatever time
but
to me
like i said if you want to be like
memorable
you have to stand out
and a lot of the
stars
didn't stand out because there were a
lot of them there were a lot of
good-looking men there were a lot of
good-looking women they were generic
that were heroes they were always the
good guys or you know the good women or
whatever in movies but it's like you
don't really remember them well king
kong
you remember fay ray a little bit
but the leading man in that you don't
remember his name you remember kong
though i don't even remember there being
a leading man in that yeah that's how
remember
there was a guy who is sort of an actor
who's just i can't bring up his face
though yeah i can i can bring up
i can bring up faye ray's face yeah
but you can't bring up the leading man
honestly king kong everybody just thinks
of king kong yeah like the monster he
starred in that movie
that's what i'm saying
yeah i'm saying and honestly that's why
the horror genre i would argue is the
best genre not only because i mean
i don't know
it's kind of a [ __ ] because
horror is good because it's the most
to me it's the most diverse genre you
can do pretty much anything within
horror and it's still kind of considered
horror
um
and horror fans
are the most
as far as i've uh seen are the most
diverse in the sense of watching [ __ ]
from like every
era tivo's saying goodbye okay bye
teetha bye tila she gotta get somebody
okay i get that i mean we've been going
forward we're gonna eat a bit too well
like i said i'm still talking about
peter cushing i want to give peter
cushing like a short shrift because we
talked about christopher lee for a long
time all right
uh so i forgot where i was so yeah so
okay so we couldn't do an american
accent liv uh olivier was kind of like
well thanks for not wasting my time on
that [ __ ] but he did give him like a
part in uh hamlet later on like i said
that was the first time that him and
christopher lee have been a movie
together although don't think they met
at the time or if they did it was like
not that big a deal they didn't really
like meet until curse of frankenstein in
1957 but they had been in a couple of
movies uh together prior so there was uh
that whole thing
holy [ __ ]
drop it
holy [ __ ] it happens
it it does it does happen
uh so yeah so even though okay so he'd
been in a movie with lawrence olivier
for christ's sake uh that movie
uh his hamlet adaptation lawrence
olivier's hamlet adaptation actually won
an oscar
so peter cushing did get some uh you
know accolades from that but like i said
it was a very small role so he was
having a hard time
finding roles and he was getting so
stressed out that he was uh essentially
having like what he called an extended
nervous breakdown
uh he was in a lot of little roles at
this point he was in like some theater
stuff he was in like radio
uh he was in again moulin rouge which i
brought up earlier uh christopher lee
played uh george zurot in that
uh uh peter cushing played like a
fictional character in that so they're
both fairly small roles because that's
mostly about toluso trek
uh and at this point uh his wife peter
cushing's wife says
why don't you get into doing tv
now at this point like i said movies
were kind of like the [ __ ]
doing tv
i feel like at that point was kind of a
step down but
peter cushing's wife was very prescient
because she was like well i feel like tv
is kind of like taking off
so maybe you should get into that kind
of stuff
so he started getting into british tv
and over the next three years he
actually
became kind of a big star like on
british tv because
again this was like you know 1950s
and tv was kind of a new medium
and so you know he was kind of
a pioneer in that uh sense i kind of
feel like
and it's interesting because
i do kind of feel like there was this
whole thing it's funny that nowadays
people talk about like oh the internet
and streaming and [ __ ] like that and how
it affects movies but back in the 50s
when tv first became
widespread
culturally
um
movie makers were kind of like oh [ __ ]
this is gonna like affect our bottom
line nobody's gonna come to see movies
anymore because everybody's gonna be
watching [ __ ] on tv
so there was this still kind of like
and i kind of feel like this persisted
probably until the 90s
maybe
where
being in movies was more prestigious
than being in tv
i kind of feel like that distinction has
vanished nowadays now that tv streaming
[ __ ] like it the distinctions don't
really matter anymore but for a long
time
like you would be in movies and then
when you were a quote-unquote has-been
you'd be like on tv shows what the [ __ ]
man you were having i'm not that drunk
i'm not that you are maybe i am not that
drunk what are we we're talking about
not that joke
okay can you contribute to the
conversation or yeah okay so what we
were talking about
what we're talking about is that
uh up until i kind of feel like maybe it
was up until the 80s or 90s
being in movies was seen as more
prestigious
than being on tv yeah i feel like that
distinction has disappeared
um because nowadays being on quote
unquote tv or streaming or whatever um
honestly that has the same cachet as
being in movies because
so many people watch stuff on streaming
nowadays
i feel like like i said the distinction
between
movies in the theater and
tv you watch at home
has not
like like i said that distinction has
disappeared so i don't really feel like
there's a
distinction anymore but there used to be
in my opinion being on movies it's not
that cool anymore and tv is just
invisible there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
tv
but people under 50 don't even know
about it i'm not talking about tv i'm
talking about tv
um
when i was up in the park
streaming services yeah no i'm talking
about
well no
i'm not talking about that
when i was a go to the biker bar they
got tv playing on those [ __ ] screens
and i'm like they still have tv shows
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
i'm like i can't believe it and it's
stupid it's real [ __ ] stupid
and they're commenting on what's on
youtube
but i'm not talking about that kind of
tv i'm talking about like streaming yeah
i'm talking about real tv i'm talking
about streaming tv like no one's talking
about that that's like old people shape
yeah that's all people [ __ ] that's what
i'm saying but i'm just saying that
before this before now yeah there used
to be because i remember this from the
80s and maybe the 90s
um you know if you were in movies that
was a big deal
but
people that were like in the movies back
in the old days but were like has-beens
then you'd be in like you'd be a guest
star like on someone's tv show yeah like
on cbs or some [ __ ] and that would be
like oh how far the mighty have fallen
it'd be like that kind of situation and
that doesn't exist anymore but back then
you know it was kind of thing but you
had to think
that back when tv was first a thing like
in the 50s when it was first becoming
widespread there was a whole different
dynamic because movie makers were kind
of like oh [ __ ] this tv
business is like cutting into our [ __ ]
and so there was this whole thing so i
don't really know but peter cushing
or at least his wife was kind of like
you really need to get into this tv
thing because this is gonna you know go
big and that actually did end up working
out well for him because he did get into
a lot of british tv and became very very
well known on british tv
back in the days when
it was kind of like i mean he was kind
of ahead of his time in doing that well
we remember that era
i mean i don't remember the 50s
obviously because i wasn't born 70s and
80s but i do remember still going on
yeah you had people that
were movie stars going on the television
television and movie were very separate
in the 70s and 80s oh yeah big time
and like i said once you saw like a
movie star yeah and if they came on like
a tv show you knew that they were like
that was over that was the end right
yeah because you're like a has been
there wasn't really any questions
and a television star just they just
didn't show up in movies it was two
different [ __ ]
worlds which is crazy because when
nowadays it's like nope there's not real
distinction they're all kind of bad
well it's there's not a distinction
nowadays because everyone kind of like
wants the way that we
interact with the media is different
well television cable television is a
lot worse
well and like i said the way you
the way that consumers if you want to
call them that interact with the media
you interact with movies and tv shows
the same yeah um you're just like
watching them on a streaming service the
standard now i would say would be for
the united
netflix st something well like i said
streaming it's like our television sure
yeah so which encompasses movies tv
series anything so like i said i think
that distinction is not
and i think people that grew up in this
era would not recognize that that was
even a distinction because to them it's
just like all entertainment it doesn't
really matter if it's tv or movies and
honestly i think that's a better way of
looking at it because it's dumb to think
that oh well movies are obviously better
than tv because it's you should see
they're kind of like the same thing you
should see american cable television
right now it's like taking a time warp
to 20 years in the past it's [ __ ]
bizarre
mango says uh cushing played winston
smith and bbc adaptation of 1984 that's
what i was just going to say i kind of
feel like that was sort of
his breakout role even though it was
very controversial at the time but yeah
in 1954 he did play
uh winston in 1984 which was done by
nigel neal who
people of uh you know a british
extraction
will know he did a bunch of stuff for
like british tv and stuff including
uh the stone tape he did the stone tape
i'm pretty sure
uh which was about
you would love it probably the stone
tape was about
poltergeist well ergos
and how ghosts were caused by
energy seeping
into uh stones which kind of like
recorded it you know what i mean like a
like a tape kind of situation it's good
though i've seen it
but yeah nigel nail wrote that but yeah
he he did an adaptation of 1984 and that
was kind of like he'd been a lot of
stuff but that was kind of like what got
him
biggest uh you know accolades at the
time
now after he was in
1984 he was in 31 other tv plays and a
couple of cereals won a bunch of awards
during this time period
um
but peter cushing not super into like
doing tv because like
like i said back in the old days i kind
of feel like tv was more
i don't know it wasn't always live but
it was always kind of like uh you know
they were
filming everything like really quickly
you know what i mean so you couldn't do
like multiple takes you couldn't do this
whole thing peter cushing very much a
perfectionist
very much wanting to everything to be
exactly the way he wanted it so he much
preferred like film making
so tv for him was very uh stressful so
he didn't really like enjoy it
you know what i mean uh so
he did tv because he had to
but he was way more into like making
movies
but the thing about it though was that
during this time period movie roles
kind of difficult to come by because
uh again like we mentioned earlier tv
movie it was like two different worlds
and people didn't really
cotton to people like trying to cross
genres i guess you know movie actors
trying to be in tv or tv actors trying
to be at movies people didn't really
want to see it
and there was kind of a thing too where
it was like different production
companies and
film producers were like we don't really
want you know all these like tv stars
over here they're like drawing
audiences away it's like it's this whole
competition thing and they didn't really
want to do it
uh so you know so he was in that he was
in a couple movies during this time
period he was in a movie called the
black knight from 1954.
uh he was also in a movie called the end
of the affair in 1955 which was adapted
from a graeme green novel
um he was also in a movie called
magic fire in 1955 which was about
rickard wagner the german composer
now during this time period
uh peter cushing started reading in
trade publications about this little old
uh you know movie
making studio called hammer
and he was kind of like well they're
looking to make
frankenstein
into a new movie
so peter cushing was like man i i really
like that book when i was a kid so
he called his agent and said why don't
you call them and see what you can set
up with that
now at this point uh
the studio executives actually had
already been looking at peter cushing at
this point because they'd seen him in a
bunch of stuff and they're like oh
if he called us that would be [ __ ]
awesome apparently they hadn't called
him at this point but his agent called
them and he was like
we were waiting for you to call we
wanted you to play this [ __ ] part
so uh at this point uh because i guess
like the guy that had co-founded the
studio was like really into peter
cushing's work and had been like
kind of like stalking him from afar i
guess i don't know it was this kind of
thing
uh so
i it must be said peter cushing at this
point
um
many years older than dr frankenstein
was in the book
so as i mentioned
previously peter cushing didn't really
he'd been acting for many years
but he didn't really get his big break
until he was
in his 40s
so when he was asked to play dr
frankenstein he was actually 20 years
older
than the part
in the book
but they didn't really care about it
because it's peter [ __ ] cushing what
are you gonna do
so they uh let him be in the curse of
frankenstein in 1957 which like i said
that was the first time that he and
christopher lee had met
and they would be subsequently in
several other movies together they'd
been in a couple together prior to this
but they didn't really meet each other
they met each other on the set of this
and were in several movies together uh
subsequently
now honestly
he says i love this quote he says who
wants to see me as hamlet very few
but millions want to see me as
frankenstein so that's the one i do so
like i said he seemed to have
even though it was an actor he'd seem
like yeah i'm going to be on the same
roll all the time um but
he seemed to have been very uh
circumcised
circumspect and like very cool about
look this is what people want to see me
in so this is what i'm gonna do and when
he's in a movie
he gives it his [ __ ]
best and he gives it his all
every single person i never found a
single quote of anybody talking bad
about him ever
um every single person that ever worked
with him said he is like a consummate
professional he would learn his part he
would learn everyone else's part and he
was like super into the process even if
he didn't love the movie even if the
movie sucked he was just like [ __ ]
there man and like i said we talked
about this before when we talk about
nicholas cage i love that [ __ ] that's
your job do the best job you can do and
that's essentially what he did
christopher lee did it as well
they never phoned it in and i love that
now interestingly though
when he played
frankenstein um
[Music]
the thing about frankenstein in the
movies that he was in because he was in
like five frankenstein movies i think
five
six i can't remember but he was in a
bunch of frankenstein movies for hammer
and the way that frankenstein is
portrayed in the hammer movies not
exactly like the one in the book
but
i'm kind of into it though they portray
him a little bit negatively but i like
the way
that peter cushing plays it because he
gets
crazier and crazier
as the movies go like his madness
escalates and i'm kind of into that you
know what i mean um
you know what i mean so they did
actually have him be like a more
unsympathetic character because in
uh you know the first one they actually
did have him
uh kill somebody
to get parts
whereas that didn't really happen in the
it's you know in the book he was just
like a grave rapper mainly and he just
you know he just saw like hubris and
stuff
but in the movies he was more like
actively
i'm gonna kill some [ __ ] like
to get some parts i want and honestly in
one of the later movies i don't think
this was in the american one
in one of the later movies
peter cushing's character
as frankenstein
does rape a woman
uh peter cushing was not happy about it
they did put it in the movie at least in
the uk the european cut i think they cut
it out in the american one because i
think at that point who wants to see
peter cushing rape somebody come on he's
such a nice man but you know what i mean
that did happen and like some of them
but like i said that's what i'm saying
it's like he was
willing to let dr frankenstein be
unlikable or be you know like a [ __ ]
villain
more than in the book even he was kind
of they were like pushing the envelope
with that
um
yeah so when he was in the first
frankenstein film
he was so into it as i said he was very
meticulous about every role that he did
however
the movie the [ __ ] was
he wanted to do the [ __ ] best he
would do
so
he actually got trained by a surgeon
to learn how to
do the scalpel and all that kind of
stuff
in the in the movie
uh so the movie which only cost 65 000
pounds
uh you know
it actually uh did
amazingly well everybody was super into
that [ __ ] because like i said
[ __ ] gory everybody loved it
so uh
this movie was so successful that both
peter cushing and christopher lee were
pretty much catapulted to worldwide fame
at that point so as i said they did
several movies
with hammer
and
peter cushing would be baron
frankenstein in
five sequels revenge of frankenstein
evil of frankenstein
uh
revenge of frankenstein
frankenstein created woman frankenstein
must be destroyed frank's done the
monster from hell
uh you know there's all those
so like i said i think frankenstein the
monster from hell was the one where he
like raped somebody and they cut it out
later but you know what i mean
um so at this point like i said uh
you know we've kind of talked about this
a little bit because we already talked
about christopher lee but they'd done a
dracula in 1958 which in this country is
called horror of dracula where
christopher lee was playing the monster
and peter cushing was playing
van helsing
so this was kind of like their first
like kind of mashup i was watching
earlier
cinemassacre did a [ __ ]
they did a mashup between
peter cushing and christopher lee like
every time they did a fight in a movie
like who won
and honestly like peter cushing like
[ __ ]
crushed christopher lee because he
[ __ ] kicked his ass every single time
he's like look peter cushing made a
whole entire career out of kicking
christopher lee's ass because
christopher lee was always the bad guy
right he was always dracula he was
always the mummy or whatever and peter
cushing was always
either dr frankenstein or he was always
like the good guy he was like like ben
hellsinger he was always kind of like
that so you know it was that kind of
situation there was very few where they
kind of like teamed up they were both
good guys
mostly christopher lee was bad guy and
peter christian was a good guy
so there was you're right yeah you sure
you hungry
yeah but
yeah but
what
i'm trying to get through all this well
i'll start cooking if you want
oh so you're gonna leave
jenny
i can't do a five-hour show
i'll start cooking now and then [ __ ]
um
by the time you're done you can get
something to eat
well goodness okay
um i still have a lot to go but yeah i
noticed okay this should have been two
shows
not really okay i mean i could have got
through it all right
i mean i can skip through
a lot of stuff but you know there's that
so let's just uh skip ahead because he's
rushing me i'm not rushing you i'm just
trying to bring some sanity to this i'm
not though
i'm not all right
all right so as i mentioned
you can go if you're just gonna sigh the
whole time
are you going to sigh the whole time
are you going to contribute or no
i don't have anything to say about it
you know i have all you're the one that
has all the all the notes on it
but you know
there's
we have to be realistic when it comes to
time you know
i'll tell you what i'm gonna start uh
cooking how would you like a uh like an
omelet or something yeah that's fine
sound good okay
all right
damn don't unplug my [ __ ] i'm not
[ __ ] it
danny rowling says
i could have seen christopher lee doing
a halloween commercial for tombstone
pizza dressed to dracula
i mean
they did at least both of them did have
a sense of humor about it because they
did like do some comedy [ __ ] about it
later on
um
but yeah i could see that i could see
that
all right so
um yeah so there was that where was i
yeah so we talked about dracula 80 1972
which if you've seen it it's like the
groovy update of dracula you can go if
you want no i'm good okay
if you're just gonna like sit there oh
this is during this if you're gonna look
at me and sigh i'm just like i'm not
into it if you're not contributing yeah
i'm gonna cook or something hold on okay
i'm vegan all right you guys have a good
one with people
back to bed
what you doing
oh you knock it off
all right so
let's see where were we okay so as i
said christopher lee
not super happy about playing dracula
and like some of the subsequent dracula
movies he didn't really want to do them
but you know
uh there was that they did however
uh both
reprise their roles
in the satanic rites of dracula in 1974
which
not a great movie but still watchable
it's always watchable uh in the us it
was called can't dr count draculin is
vampire bride which
i don't know i live in the us have never
heard it called that i always called it
i always heard it called the satanic
rights of dracula but whatever
um at this point uh peter cushing also
played van helsing in the legend of the
seven golden vampires which was all
which was kind of like a vampire movie
that was hamper the hammer studios and
also
shaw brothers so it was kind of like
dracula meets
hong kong uh cinema
chinese martial arts so there was that
um i've seen that but it's been a while
so i don't really remember
how great it was uh just gotta say
now at this point peter cushing uh as
christopher lee realized was going to be
typecast in horror roles
but uh again cushing was like hey it
pays the bills so i'm not really all
that worried about it
but he did kind of try to branch out a
little bit he was in some other [ __ ]
though uh other than hammer films he was
in a movie called the abominable snowman
from 1957 which was actually that was
actually hammer but it was an adaptation
of
the nigel neal
tv play the creature which had
uh telecast on 19 in 1955. peter cushing
had also been in that as well
and there was also the mummy which i
mentioned earlier uh with cushing
playing the archaeologist and
peter cushing
or peter grisham playing they already
got archaeologist christopher lee
playing the monster um the thing about
that which is interesting and this kind
of like uh leads back to what i was
saying earlier
with peter cushing always trying to like
give his
opinions about stuff
was that
on the poster for the mummy which i
guess they produced before the movie was
made or finished
they had an image of the mummy that had
like this
uh
kind of like hole in his chest and it
was kind of like this big thing coming
out of the hole
and peter cushing was like what's that
all about that doesn't really happen in
the movie and they're like yeah well we
just did that for the poster whatever
the [ __ ] and he's like well
yeah but can i do something that looks
like that for the movie though and they
were kind of like i guess like if you
want so at that point like peter cushing
actually did
end up having a scene where he drove
harpoon through the mummy and like made
a big hole in his chest to like actually
make it look like the poster because
like i said the poster had been made
before the movie was done they weren't
actually intending to put anything like
that the movie
thanks to peter cushing that was
actually in there
again as i mentioned earlier peter
cushing played sherlock holmes a [ __ ]
ton of times
um including in the head of the
baskervilles which i watched today which
came out in 1959
and uh he played him in a
bbc series as well which i think aired
in 1968 although i think a lot of those
uh episodes have vanished although a few
of them do still exist on youtube
uh he also
showed up as the sheriff of nottingham
in uh sort of sherwood forest that was
1960
and he was in cash on demand which
somebody mentioned earlier as somebody
that's like
a kind of cranky capitalist ebenezer
scrooge type character that was 1961
and uh as i mentioned earlier uh cushing
considered this
the favorite of his films even though
very few people have seen it and
honestly i have not seen it either but
i've heard that it's very good so i will
be watching that also
so it was in a couple other movies then
uh we talked about the gorgon 1964 which
i watched today
she 1965 which i believe he was in that
with christopher lee that's
i think a remake of the serial from the
1930s if i'm if i'm not mistaken because
i think i've seen that as well
uh he was also in the vampire lovers
from 1970
uh which
did we review that
maybe not i kind of feel like woods i
don't know i've seen it but yeah
um he was also in lust for a vampire
uh or was supposed to be in lesbian
vampire but couldn't be in it
but he was in twins of evil which we did
review
and then there was fear in the night
from 1972 another uh hammer roll one of
his final ones
and honestly it's kind of like
he was in a bunch of stage stuff
uh and various other things at that
point i kind of feel like tom left now
so we talked about
doctor who he was in a couple of doctor
who movies
one of one of which was called doctor
who in the daleks from 1965 which i've
seen
um i saw it on rift tracks
full disclosure it's not
great uh as always peter cushing is the
best thing in it the rest of it
not so much uh the other one he was in
was called daleks invasion earth 2150
a.d which is from 1966 which i have not
seen he played him as i said unlike the
tv
doctor who in the sense that he was kind
of just like a human
mad scientist type character
rather than an extraterrestrial
interdimensional whatever
um
so you know it's as tom mentioned it's
probably non-canonical i don't really
know enough about doctor who to say but
you know there's that
so uh yeah
as i mentioned he played sherlock holmes
a [ __ ] ton of times he also wrote some
uh
you know four words for books about
sherlock holmes
and he was in some amicus films as well
some of which we've reviewed
uh including dr cherry's house of
horrors the skull which we did review i
remember that uh torture garden and he
was also in a couple called uh the blood
beast terror from 1968 and island of
terror and he was in one called uh the
beast must die which
spoiler alert i'm going to be reviewing
this coming saturday i just watched it
recently
uh he was also on some comedy shows in
the late 1960s
and as someone mentioned he was an eye
monster in 1971 which is like a jekyll
and hyde type story
and he um
was kind of in a couple movies but he
was kind of taking care of his ailing
wife at the time so he did a lot of
audiobook narration uh for for the blind
and things like that uh during this time
period he was in dr feeds rises again in
1972 with vincent price which was the
sequel to abominable dr phebes and then
he was in mad house which also has which
also had dr uh duck had vincent price in
1974.
um and he was in some amicus anthology
films tales from the crypt which is
great from beyond the grave and now the
screaming starts which maybe were
reviewed
i can't remember if we did uh and the
beast must die which like i said i
am going to be reviewing this coming
saturday he also did like some stage
stuff he was in some movies with donald
pleasance uh played
you know sherlock holmes a couple other
times played arthur conan doyle once
and uh obviously as many of you probably
know joined the cast of star wars 1976.
interestingly like george lucas asked
him to be like you know he was a big fan
so he asked him to be in the movie
and at the time that star wars came out
which is crazy to think about nowadays
peter cushing and alec guinness uh
obviously you played obi-wan kenobi were
like the bret the best um i said press
the best known actors at the time
because
everybody else who was in it harrison
ford you know carrie fisher's uh you
know mark hamill stuff like that we're
not really all that well known so the
older actors were kind of well known
the hilarious thing uh peter cushing and
david prouse who played uh you know
darth vader even though he didn't do the
voice but he was the physical presence
of darth vader uh peter cushing and
david prowse had worked together before
uh in frankenstein the monster from hell
so they got together famously of course
peter cushing and carrie fisher
uh got to get got along really well
carrie fisher said the one scene
the very famous scene in star wars like
honestly one of the first scenes in the
movie where they're arguing about uh you
know grand moff tarkin like blowing up
alderaan
and she's like talking [ __ ] to him and
stuff that was one of the scenes first
scenes that they filmed together
and carrie fisher said later and she's
like that was a really hard film to see
like seeing the film because
um i had to pretend like i hated him but
i liked it like he was so awesome and i
liked him so much that it was like
really really difficult so there was
that kind of so she had to like picture
someone else while she was talking to
him while they like shot that [ __ ]
uh so yeah um honestly let's see he was
also most people know in rogue one which
came out in 2016 very awesome movie they
essentially brought him back to life
because he died in 1984
so they had to bring it back to life
with cgi
so there was that
um interestingly too uh probably y'all
will find this very interesting is that
peter cushing was actually originally
approached by john carpenter
to play sam loomis in the original
halloween christopher lee was also
approached both of them turned it down
which is how donald pleasance famously
ended up with the role but john
carpenter was like obviously a big fan
of his
uh so
1983 one of the last
movies that they did together there was
a movie called house of the long shadows
that was 1983 and christopher lee
vincent price and peter cushing were in
that was kind of like a horror comedy
parody type of situation that was one of
the last things they were all in
together
um so peter cushing was in some like
comedy top secret i think wasn't [ __ ]
what's his name val
whenever the fucker's name is yeah he
was in that
he was in a couple movies in the 80s but
and he wrote a couple autobiographies
but after that it was kind of like he
was uh his health was declining because
honestly from 1982
he got diagnosed with
prostate cancer and even though
this is [ __ ] this is crazy so 1982 he
gets rushed to a hospital because his
one eye was like swollen
like to three times its
usual size they took him to a hospital
and they said yeah you have prostate
cancer
um you have maybe a year year and a half
to live
they told him
peter cushing lived another
12
years without any other
intervention or at least any major
intervention he didn't have like any
chemo or anything like that but he did
live another 12 years although his
health did decline over that time and he
didn't really uh work much during that
point
so uh he actually
ended up checking himself into a hospice
in
in summer of 1994
and he died in late august
at 81
years old now as i mentioned earlier he
had like a lot of
other interests like i said he was the
quintessential actor he was really into
it from a young age
uh but he was really into one of the
things he was into which i thought was
very strange well not strange but
interesting
was that he liked to
collect model soldiers like he had all
these little model soldiers and he would
paint them and like he would set up
battles and stuff and he did that like
he was really into that
um he was also into a lot into drawing
he painted like watercolors
and he was really into animals he was
really into bird watching he was
actually like a vegetarian most of his
life and was really um kind of hardcore
into vegetarian causes like he didn't
really like to eat animals or you know
cruelty animals at any point
um and as i said he was very very into
i mean everybody that knew him just said
he was like the quintessential
gentleman gentleman he was just very
gentle he was very soft-spoken he was
very professional he would come on set
he would learn his own [ __ ] he would
learn everybody else's [ __ ] and he would
try to make the [ __ ] as good as it could
be
um you know but he wasn't
obnoxious in any way like i saw nobody
that had a bad word about him same with
christopher lee honestly nobody had a
bad word to say about either one of them
and i will say that
this is yeah i mentioned this earlier
so 1971 peter cushing's wife
died
of emphysema
and uh they had been married at this
point since 1943.
so peter cushing very famously said that
his life ended when hers did um
he published an autobiography which came
out in 1886
and it didn't talk about his life after
1971 like after she had died
1972 they did an interview with him
uh on the radio times and he said
since helen passed on i can't find
anything the heart quite simply has gone
out of everything
time is interminable the loneliness is
almost unbearable and the only thing
that keeps me going is the knowledge
that my dear helen and i will be
reunited again someday to join helen is
my only ambition you have my permission
to publish that really you know dear boy
it's all just killing time please say
that
and honestly that was 1972
and he didn't die until 1994. and
honestly him and christopher lee were
friends all that time and christopher
lee
said too like later on he's like yeah
basically he did like he was still in
movies and he still worked and he was
still like a lovely person to be around
but they said something like went out of
him like after his wife died and he was
just kind of like waiting around which
to me like seemed really really sad
there was another thing too that when he
wrote his uh later autobiography because
he wrote two
peter cushing actually said
not outright but he said that he maybe
the night that his wife died
that he kind of hoped that he had died
too they said that he like ran up and
down the stairs hoping that he would
have a heart attack
and that he would die but that later on
he said that well that was just like
hysteria i was just panicking i wasn't
really
thinking clearly and i didn't really
hope i would die but
there was that
um
honestly he had like a lot of physical
problems after she died like he lost a
lot of weight he had like a lot of like
stress problems so you know there was
that too
and it's kind of like sad
um christopher lee actually says uh and
this is a quote from 1994
he says about peter cushing he says
there was something a little bit
different about peter waiting for the
end for 23 years
since his beloved wife helen died his
friends realized that he wouldn't mind
packing up on this earth to join her
vincent price once in a phone call to me
asked is he still expecting helen to be
there to greet him
and i said looking forward to it and
vincent said
what if she's out
which like seems really mean but
i mean i don't know i guess these dudes
were like friends for a long time but
but said what if she's out
and i be meaning christopher lee said i
shall tell him you said that vincent
and when i did peter laughed fit to
dispatch him immediately on his journey
when he recovered he'd said only vincent
could say such a thing and only you
could pass it on which
to me that kind of like sums up the
whole like essence of these dudes like
these two dudes these three dudes like
including vincent rice their whole like
relationship that they could
make a joke about something that [ __ ]
profound
and they would still like take it in the
spirit intended like because to me like
reading it from as an outsider it sounds
like mean spirited but because they all
knew each other i guess they didn't take
it that way
um because like yeah you're waiting all
this time to like meet your wife what if
she's not there like if what if she's
like toddled off to the lou or whatever
and uh but they just thought it was like
kind of funny and i thought that was
like kind of sweet so i don't know
but this whole i don't know this is
bumming me out this whole situation uh
yeah all right so where are we doo doo
doo danny rolling says friday friday the
batman comes out we're gonna go see that
on friday actually well maybe maybe not
on friday but
we'll probably see it this weekend i
kind of feel like i wanted to see that
it looks really good you know what i'm
saying
um
rebecca says when disney cgi
rose rogue one he popped up as an
amazing cgi but they didn't notify his
living family but disney had to
apologize yeah i mean
i kind of feel like they did sort of
maybe
um i think they did actually tell his
daughter i want to say or they told
somebody and his family
uh because she went to see it and she
was like holy [ __ ] that looks amazing it
did it didn't look
entirely real you could still tell it
was cgi but it was still impressive
enough that i was okay with it but they
were okay with it um they thought it was
pretty cool
but
i don't know it's weird but i guess they
were kind of happy about it because
they're like oh look it looks like he's
alive again because it's weird because
he died
such a long time before christopher lee
he died in 1994. christopher ledin died
until 2015 which is [ __ ] crazy so all
the [ __ ] time but yeah if you go on
youtube there's all kind of like
you know [ __ ] with like the two of them
like talking together
there's interviews with christopher lee
like talking about peter cushing it's
like [ __ ] awesome but yeah so if you
want to know there's like a list of i
have a list but i'm not going to say it
because there's like tons of other ones
but there were 24 movies that they were
actually in together not all of them
like some of the early ones like hamlet
and mulan rouge and [ __ ] like that they
were just kind of like you know they
were in the movie but they weren't like
together in the movie they were just
like bit parts
but starting with curse of frankenstein
from 1857 uh they did a [ __ ] ton of
movies together for hammer and for other
studios and they're all definitely worth
watching
um honestly horror of dracula probably
my favorite but
curse of frankenstein is good the mummy
is good how do the baskervilles is
awesome
um i mean all of them are definitely
worth watching so you probably should a
bunch of them are
i saw a couple of them on
2b there are a couple of them on shutter
so they're all over the place so you can
like totally see them anything both of
them are in is fantastic and actually
anything
either one of them is in is fantastic so
you know
seriously uh just
well hi pook um yeah so
i guess it's been like more than four
hours
tom has taken off
and i really have to
you know
end the show i suppose
but this has been fun talking about
two of my favorite horror movie icons i
hope you guys enjoyed it
um you know but we will be back
friday evening at 5 p.m doing our side
track show just talking about whatever
and
hopefully you guys will join us for that
thank you for dropping by thank you for
all the super chats
and hopefully we'll see you again on
friday night we will see you again
then bye